Believe in wireless, he needs to
see it. Boom. And we're alive.
What's that bridge? How are you man spot
maybe let's go on. They're doing this.
I really appreciate it. Thank you
for having me on the show, man. Well,
I read about you a fellow Boston native
and I've read about your Tesla journey
and I was like, this is a
fucking interesting story.
This guy buys a broken Tesla,
right? And then you couldn't
get parts for it anywhere.
So what had happened to the car? It
had been in an accident. No. So the, I,
I met the previous owner and he actually,
I was think it was during Hurricane
Sandy. He thought that, uh, he goes,
wait a minute, that water level seems
a low enough me to drive through it.
And he just had a driving through the
water. I think it got up to like the, uh,
almost like the B pillar. Oh No. Where
his neck is. Yeah. Yeah, I know. Right.
So he thought he could fight the
water. He lost obviously. And um,
it was just underwater and I'm like,
you know what, I got to try this thing.
And so what,
what would Tesla do in that situation?
If he wanted to bring it back to them?
They would have to rebuild the entire car.
They wouldn't even do it because at that
point, uh, once, uh, anything liquid,
you know, any kind of like water
intrusion happens at an e v face. Right.
The whole car off insurance companies
just like, we're not going to do it.
Too risky. Too risky, not worth it.
Were you aware of the Fisker a dilemma
at the hurricane sandy when they had a,
the Fiskars that were parked at the,
it was like at a,
some sort of a doc right to ship.
They all exploded.
They all burned water level rose.
The water got into them and they just
went off and they fucking fire loss the
whole bunch of them. Yeah.
Look, this is a video of it.
You could watch the video
of them fucking blowing up.
So as the water level rose and then
you'd see the water breaching. Yeah.
Well the water gets to the cars
and when it gets to the cars,
they just start going off like,
fucking fuck all. Yeah. Oh yeah,
I know that feeling. Oh yeah, let's
look at that. Boom, boom, boom.
I know.
It was like a supernova.
I mean those are big ass fucking
batteries. Just blowing that slideshow.
It turns night in the day. It's amazing
how many, they lost like 40 cards up,
Nigga. They lost a fuck load and
the company essentially went,
they went radio silent. Yeah, for
like a year. That's a bigL to take.
Once they realize their car could just
explode out. That's not good. Sorry,
what happened? This, this video po? I
didn't look at the name of the video.
It popped up when I typed it
into the Fisker explosion,
but this was the explosion of the con
Ed plant. Oh, that's a big difference.
That was a John [inaudible] those cars.
But there is a video of the actual
Fiskars exploding, isn't there?
There's definitely pictures. Pictures.
The second video won't be as exciting now.
Yeah, let's leave it off. Fuck it.
This information set us back an hour.
So that's the cars. That's
what it was left to them. Wow.
And they all fucking blew up. It's
a beautiful car though. Fisker.
Did a great job of making a car.
That looks really good. Right.
But you know what's funny?
I,
I think the backends kind of ugly to
you think the front was like a fish.
The back's kind of ugly and that
actually, have you ever driven one? No.
Been in one. When you drive
one you'll be like, ah,
I get why this doesn't work out well
Justin Bieber had a all chrome one.
I remember that dad. Does he still have
it though? Cause you still have it.
He probably, he probably
doesn't even know. Yeah,
he probably doesn't know at this point.
Yeah. You know the amount of money.
That dude myself probably has no idea
if he has that car. Little kitten.
It's got it tucked away somewhere. But
what do they drive? Like they're just,
they're just not really great card.
It's not really a driver's car.
It's a two plus two. The a the center
keeps thing like you're closer to, sorry.
Sorry.
Can moves around if you want to take away.
The center console is super wide.
It's a super awkward car to drive and
it's not really good at really anything,
you know, it doesn't styling
wise, I'm like, yeah.
So you think that back end looks ugly?
I don't think I could that much. No. No,
but you know what's funny?
The chroma isn't looked that bad.
Some guy got arrested in Germany.
They pulled them over and it compounds
it his car cause he had a gold shiny wrap
on it. Right. It was a two
reflective or something.
I see now there's a couple of instances
they'll let you do that in America,
but in Germany they're like,
fuck off.
They took that Shit Bruh. You
know, they're like harsh, cold,
stoic folk, you know, they
don't want you doing that.
They don't want you flexing too
much over there. Not Too much. No.
I bet they were like reluctantly are
making cars like super flashy for like
American markets and shit. I think
so too. I, you know, I wonder.
You think so? I don't know.
I don't know. Yeah, I me,
I wonder how much of an influence it has.
Like if you could leave
them to themselves, right.
What kind of crops did they,
yeah. Yeah, cause I feel like
so much of it is market driven,
but they,
when it comes to like engineering and
handling like God damn German cars have it
nailed. They really do. They really do
nail, you know what the Americans are.
They were trying to sneak up
and get clothes for a while.
But I mean like the Germans
just this, this, this,
the standard benchmark for every place
for the Americans fuck with it is like,
have you ever driven a
Camaro? Zl One I have. Yeah.
That's a preposterous car. It's an awesome
car. It's amazing. I have a um, uh,
a corvette, z o six oh six
oh six, which is, you know,
the [inaudible] seven liter and uh,
it's an insane Chi by today's standards.
It already has like 505 horsepower.
Funny. But like, it's, it's not a lot.
It's a mean. It's a mean car. The car,
I'll put you on your ass really
quick, man. Talking to a man,
our friend Taylor out there was telling
us that they put a a Tesla in ludicrous
mode on a dyno and it had
some insane number of Torque,
right?
900 pound pound feet of
Torque and somewhere in the
neighborhood of a thousand
horsepower and the dyno
could believe and read it.
A lot of times they even go that
high in a lot of cases. Yeah,
they're insane cars, man. I'm telling
you, the Americans know how to do it now.
I think it's interesting that you know,
people don't realize this
when they see a Tesla,
it's a fully American car and they don't
realize that. They're just like, oh,
it's probably something like,
you know, German or Japanese car,
but the is 100% made here. Is
this it right here, Jamie? Yes.
Is this the, which model is
this p 100 days. 100 days.
So that's the biggest one. So what
does it say? Cause on a Mustang dyno.
So we're going to go from like
a 20 mile an hour roll sound.
Like these little boys will
tell you this Tesla or a peer,
or figure out how fast she goes.
I think I can get it to jump.
I thought it said 56 six. Yeah.
No, I think it a look at them. Hey,
even almost jumps off the dyno at
this point. There's so much torque.
Yeah, it's a very, very, very powerful car
when I'm trying to describe it to people,
especially people that have never
driven an electric car. I'm like,
it doesn't even seem real.
It seems like it violates physics.
So how do you like yours,
by the way? So I know.
I know that Ilan Musk came
here and bamboos that you
into buying one pretty much.
How dare you? I love it.
I love it. It's great,
isn't it? It makes other cars
seemed stupid. Right? And I
love cars. Oh yeah. I know.
You're a car guy. I loved them. I love
cars that don't even drive that fast.
I love mechanical engineered excellence.
I love that when people figure things out.
Right. Which is what brought me to you.
I love the fact that you took this
car that was fucked up, right?
And you refuse to let it go.
Do you like I'm going to figure
out how to fix this fucking thing.
How much did you buy it for? What? It was
15 grand. Just to be clear on something.
I'm not like some like
evil genius or brainiac.
This was driven by my cheapness because
I didn't want to spend the kind of money
they were asking for one. Right? So,
so basically this car is like 15 grand
and the whole story started with,
my friend came over, he actually had a
job at Tesla and he's like, buddy, listen,
do these crazy cars. I know you have a
zero six but this car is faster than that.
You're going to love this thing. I
was like, that electric crap box.
I don't want anything to do with that.
Whatever. Right? You brought the car over,
great looking car. I said all right and
I'll take it for a drive or whatever.
And the thing was amazing,
right? Amazing car.
So I was in tech and I'm
just like, listen, like,
like how much does this thing cost?
Like I make decent money, whatever.
I'll just throw some money at it. And he's
like, listen, this will cost about 120.
I said, you know what? Have
a nice day. I'm like, hi and
that shit. Um, and then he,
so he laughed and I thought to myself like
every night I was like, you know what,
I got to get my hands on one
of these cars, man. I got
to get one, like, you know,
sell a kidney, whatever, sell a
testicle, whatever I can do. And it's,
I was searching online and you know,
at what happens is whenever a
car gets messed up, whenever
a car gets a, as I say,
total than a way, and it's a
total loss and insurance company,
you'll take it and they'll kind of
auction it off to like the highest bidder.
So I went to an auction site and I
saw one for sale was like, you know,
at 15 grand, they said it didn't
run her drive and it wasn't a flood.
And I'm just like 15 grand. I could
do that. That's a piece of cake, man.
Throw some money at it.
Whatever. How hard can it be?
You stick it in a bag of rice and I tie
it up. He's like an iPhone, you know,
you've got your iPhone on the
toilet. Right. You know what I mean?
It's just like he had socks. Do you
want a bag of rice and you get to go.
So I figured out how to do it just
by more rice for this thing. And uh,
I got it home and um, I was
like, you know what, this is a,
I got myself into some shit here,
cause this,
it was a lot more work than I thought
it was going to be. Sight unseen.
I didn't see that's,
that's the way it is the most times.
They don't really let you on
the auction lots too often.
So they took five photos
of it. It was, uh,
some from the interior of some from
the side and one under the front.
And I was just like, I could probably
do this right. And no big deal.
So this begins his project,
which takes how long from to completion?
I think it took me about maybe six or
seven months or so of straight work. No.
So I have, um, so I was
working at the time and uh,
I think only between the hours of like
7:00 PM and like 11:00 PM like every
night and then weekends for a few
hours until I figured it out. Yeah.
So goodbye social life pretty much.
Yeah. I was, I was a hermit for that,
for those months. And what actually ended
up doing was, so I had the car right.
So I was freaking out because my wife
was just like, how much was that thing?
And like, I mean, of course. Yeah. She
had the divorce papers ready pretty much.
And uh, oh, is that it? I
know this is a different one.
That fucked up. Yeah, that was
really messed up. Now I couldn't say.
How much did you get that one for? That
one was about bleep guests. Four grand.
It was 20 grand. I paid for
that. Yes. Yes. Six total.
Yeah, I know. But these, they're
so valuable, man. Really,
because you know why it's the,
the,
the battery technology and the
motor technology that Tesla's using.
Everyone's just dying for
that stuff, man. So any, any,
any rec test so that you find minimum,
I know I'm spilling the secret sauce here.
Minimum Worth 15 grand. Even if it looks
like that. Dead serious. That's insane.
What that did is doesn't even have doors
yet. It took, I took the doors off,
put the battery pack is still in there.
Right.
And the motor and the motor
was still in there too.
Do people take those and put them in like
old cars or anything yet? Absolutely.
It's a he,
that's the new generation of hot rodders
cause I saw something like that about a
Mustang. It was like a 65,
66 Mustang. It was electric,
but I didn't know what train it
used. So, so you know how um,
you're a gear head, you
know this, the ls swap,
they put literally an ls into
everything lands, Land Cruiser,
Toyota Land Cruiser with one
ls. Swap went. Oh Shit. Um,
so that's the new ls swap basically. So
then the Tesla motor is the new ls swap.
Everyone is swapping at Tesla motor until
you know Volkswagen bugs and to Audi's
into, into Porsche's, into everything.
Well I know that people are doing ls swaps
into nine 11th and Porsche people are
losing their fucking minds eye now
taking old air cooled cars. Yup.
Which are really notoriously difficult
to get to a high horsepower. Exactly.
Cause those air cooled cars,
like you can only get them like
around 400 plus horsepower.
The days not crumbling unless your singer,
right?
Well they've got that insanely engineered
a new one. What does that called
Lionel late. Either way it's
going to cost you like you know,
damn near $100,000 a day, 80 pounds
something dynamic, lightweight, something.
It's the most gorgeous looking of those
portions have ever seen ever Sanders.
And they built that one up to 500 plus
horsepower, right? Yes. That's a hundred.
How much does it cost though? That's the
thing. Fucking million six. Exactly. Yeah.
Yeah. You can buy one
that's a giant house, man.
That's a house with land. You might
have a, well, actually that's not true.
And in La, that's not a house. No, but
la is not the real world. What is that?
67 Mustang meets Tesla.
Avr Motors,
all electric muscle car. Holy Fuck.
That's a 68. That's a good looking too.
That's one of the best looking ends of any
car ever. An awesome looking car. Fuck,
that looks incredible. 2.2
here to 60. There you go.
What the fuck? So that's the
new, that's new. So there's,
it was going to cost
you a ton of mark that
it's going to cost you a ton of
money to recreate that same look. Uh,
look, it has this nice screen to
what did, that's so weird though,
to not shift a muscle car.
I'm thinking about backing out and backing
it up. But you love your Tusla though.
You don't shift that,
but it doesn't look like that.
That would be a super ultra poser.
Right?
The door handles come out like a test
doesn't test the doorhandles fuck off the
next. No, no, no. There's
a company that does, um,
it's a company called Rev.
Ology.
That makes me old like
1966 to like 68 mustangs.
But they do it with all new parts.
Right.
And Modern Technical Resto Mod pretty
much not though because it's a new car
there. They buy the full, um, that's uh,
that's actually a brand new car
that's never existed. Oh really?
It's a ground up ground up built. They
buy the whole, you know, cause it's,
I think it's called the unibody
construction. Is that what it is?
There's something, the way that
these mustangs are constructed,
the body's built into the frame and
they bought this company sells them like
completed versions of the body kit that
are perfect with perfect tolerances.
Right. So like that. Like it's like
that's when they're 67 Shelby gt 500.
What's the pricing? Oh Wow. Stupid
expensive. Yeah. It's not going to work.
It's like two Teslas. Yeah, pretty
much. Yeah. But they're dope.
It's dope as fuck.
If you look at like what it looks like,
go down and see some pictures of
it, Jamie, you'd get a better,
a better sense of it. But this
guy is meticulous. Yeah. Okay.
This company's very meticulous.
I'm,
I've been following their stuff for
quite a while and what they do is really
incredible. Right? That's an all med, all
new sheet metal. I can, everything's new,
but it has some killer brakes and it
has a modern coyote Mustang engine and a
fibo.
Yup.
So it's a 460 horsepower engine and these
old ass muscle cars and that one's the
gt 500 that one's actually supercharged.
That has a 600 horsepower engine did
it's dub. They're fucking gorgeous.
They're gorgeous cars. They're really
pretty. So, so what would you think
about someone dropping an electric
motor on one of these things to see?
I love it. Look, I love, I love people
doing crazy shit, but it's not for me.
I need to shift if I'm driving that thing,
I got to pretend I'm Steve McQueen.
I hear you man.
Here's the thing.
So what do you think about the new,
you seen the new Tesla roadster, right?
Gorgeous. What do you think
about, I love it. Yeah,
but it's theirs from the bottom up.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like I don't mind not shifting in it.
That thing seems like it's going to
literally punch a hole through space time
though too, man. I think so too.
I think they're looking at it like
zero to 60 in like one point something
seconds. Yeah, I think it's one nine.
That's what they're saying. It's insane.
That's bizarre. I know. It's crazy
when you feel it in the p 100 d mine,
like everybody that I get in the car
and I stomp on the gas, they're like,
they can't believe it. They can't believe
that these are around you. It's like,
it's like vampires being around people,
but people that can just leap to the
top of buildings that walking around and
rec can regular until some shit
goes down. Yeah. No, they're,
they're absolutely amazing
cars, man. And I think that's,
that's what the main reason why I was
like, I gotta get one of these man.
So what one, what was the struggle?
Initial struggle. You have the car,
you take it apart,
and what did you see?
Pretty much I was kind of taking my time
because I knew there was a point where
I couldn't fix the damn thing.
And I was just kind of wasting
everyone's time and why it's like, Hey,
is this thing almost done? I
was like, yeah, babe, don't
worry about it. We're good.
Don't worry. Your money's safe. And, um,
so there's a certain point where I
took everything apart and I was like,
all right, cool. I found a dead fish
in the back of the car by, so actually,
you know what the turning point, this
whole thing, was that the turning point?
Yeah,
it
was, um, I, I realized it was
salt water and not fresh water.
So, you know what, saltwater does
this stuff, right? So it just,
it just kills everything. So, uh, 90%
of the car was kind of toast. And,
uh, I said to myself, all right,
I'm going to call Tesla, you know,
buy a motor by a battery pack.
I'll be good. You know what I mean?
Maybe I'll spend like 20 grand for a
battery and like maybe 10 for a motor,
I'll be enrolling for 40. It's still
cheaper than a hundred. Right, right. So,
so I called them up and uh, you
know, they were like, hey, you know,
how's it going man? I was like, Hey, you
know what a crazy thing happened, right?
So I bought this tussles
underwater and um,
I need like a couple of things and either
battery, I need like a motor, you know,
just, just throw me those things.
It's fine. They're like, well,
we're not going to sell it
to, I was like, well, why not?
Because you have no capability of
fixing the car yourself. You know,
you're gonna get yourself killed.
It's not going to work. You know,
give me your vin number. And I gave
them the vin number. They're like, no,
that car is listed as salvage.
That thing was underwater.
We're not going to help you. And just hung
up the phone pretty. Ooh. Yeah. So like,
this is the crazy part two is that
they know, you know, I'm putting,
I'm a conspiracy theorist hat on.
They know where every single car is.
They know what it's doing.
They know if the airbags went off,
they know if you farted in the front seat,
they know everything about these cars.
So pretty much when you
give them the vin number,
you know the cars are always connect it
back to the mothership to give you the
status in the car so they know
what's going on. So you know,
if you try to hide from you, just you
just can't do it. Um, so, so I had the,
I had the car and I said to myself, you
know what? This isn't going to work.
I got to figure something out.
So what I did,
basically I bought another car
for 15 grand and I was like,
I got to swap this stuff over.
So I swapped every single one
that you bought for 15 grand.
Everything worked well.
It was in a front end collision.
It was in a hard friend and collision
and the frame's bent or something frame
was bad.
The thing was toast.
And I just took all the
electronics from one to the other.
How do you check to make
sure that everything isn't
damaged when that's a good
thing?
A lot of the wiring harnesses were cut
right in the front end collision car.
But the interesting part
was that in the flooded car,
the wiring harnesses that we're still good
for the most part in the front really.
So what I did was, I mean meaning not
broken or torn or have then connectors,
I just took those connectors
off and actually cleaned
them because they couldn't
get parts, you know, from Tesla.
I took like the wet wiring harnesses
that we're all corroded, pulled them out,
got like, you know, Qtip toothbrush and
all that stuff. But he cleaned them with,
so I cleaned them with um,
with baking,
speaking soda and I'm like a wire
brush and like I got a toothpick to,
to really get in there and like
cleaning the contacts and stuff.
I just rinsed them out with water. By this
time, your wife was probably like, what?
She's pissed, he'll fall. She goes,
I noticed we're missing
$30,000 from my bank account
and two cars that don't work exactly
to credit, don't work, you know,
and there's a $30,000 a missing from our
bank account. Like, what's going on here.
So, um, it was just, it was
painstaking, but eventually, you know,
I got the job done then. So, so I
ended up doing was so 30 grand, right.
I told my friends, hey listen, you know,
I'm in a mess here and we're building
a test on it. Just like, you know,
you're an idiot, you're not going to
figure this out. Like no one's doing that.
Cause this was,
this was years ago,
this is when the cars were still kind of
coming onto the scene and they weren't
as popular as they are now. And
you're like, you can't fix that.
Like you're an idiot. You can't
do that. I've seen your work. Uh,
and uh, so yeah, so
after awhile, you know,
I took all the parts from
one of the other, um,
got one running and then the
parts I didn't need anymore,
like the, the, the old battery
pack and some of the actions.
So there were some parts of the
battery that we're still good.
So I actually sold those parts like
online and on Ebay and stuff like that.
And then I sold like the motor,
he had water in it.
Someone got give me five grand
for motor that had water in it.
That's how valuable these parts are.
So mad.
Was he planning on doing the same thing?
They're cleaning it out. I have no idea.
To this day. I don't know. So I
think he has in the same situation.
I think he brought it home to his
wife. He said, hey look what I got.
It's probably still at his house.
And uh, so after all of that,
so all the parts I ended up getting
the car I have now for about six grand.
So you take the engine and is that
one of the four wheel drive ones?
The ones you have.
This was just a rear wheel drive one.
And so it has just the rear engine.
The single motor. Yep. One engine.
And so you take those out,
you put it all back in,
you replaced the wires and then it's
good to go. What about the computer?
What about,
Gosh,
so pretty much the computer thing
was interesting because there was,
so I called Tesla again,
right? I was like, hey buddy,
like this car is like 99% of
the way there. Do you know,
do they know who you are at this point?
They still don't know who I am.
Nor do they care. They still probably
don't care who I am, but, but did you say,
hey man, you remember you
hung up on me? Yeah. Right.
The car still doesn't work.
Well, I still didn't work. Right.
So the tough part was I
had to remember I had no,
I had no key for the car. Oh. So
I was like, Hey, I need a key.
You know what I mean? Like help me out
here. He a key. And they were like, well,
are you the same idiot that called like,
yeah, I need the key. They're like,
we can't, as I stated before, we
can't help you because you know this.
This is a salvage car, so you're on your
own. So what I did was I actually in the,
in the GPS screen, because
the screen turned on the, the,
the guy still had the home location.
So I pushed home on the gps screen,
found the guy's address, right.
This is creepy. I got, gets creepy,
right? If I'm the guy's address.
And I was like, Hey, you know,
can we, uh, I called
them up. I was like, hey,
did you own like a white Tesla by
chance? And he's like, who was like,
yeah, I own one. I was like, yeah,
um, so I bought it and I need the key.
Do you have the key to the
car? And he's like, no, I
don't, I don't have that. Like,
what do you call me for like, I
don't understand. It's like, well,
I'm rebuilding it, I'm putting
the electronics from your
condo or another. And, um,
I want to figure it out. And he's
like, you know what, I can't help you.
I don't have the key. And I
was like, damn, it's socks.
You know, cause you know,
I have a family and stuff and you know,
kind of give him the sob story, like,
you know, he could read it, look for
and help me out, be good. And, uh,
we started talking about general
topics and he's like, you know,
I know you're a car guy.
That's awesome. Um, I had, uh,
I had a zero six months and I was like,
Hey, I have a zero six two. And he's like,
yeah, it was, it was Lamont's blue. And
I was like, Hey, mines the mines blue.
And he's like, what year is it? I
was like, it's an o six. He goes,
I sold that same car or car like it
like two years ago to a guy in Florida.
I was like, I bought the car from a
guy in Florida. So we started bonding.
So it turns out I actually owned his
old zero six. Yeah, it's crazy, right?
What are the odds of two human beings on
the planet? You own both of the scars.
Carlos's this guy's car. It was insane.
So he's like, listen, he goes, awesome.
You know, I'll see if I could,
I'll see if I could find, you know,
the key friends with that dude now.
No, we never talked again after that.
He was like, you should be free. Well,
here's the reason why so. Well one on one,
it was super creepy for me to call
the guy in number two. Um, when I,
when I went kind of silent for a week,
he called me back and said, buddy,
I found the key. Oh, I found the key
to the car. I was like, awesome dude.
Like you're fantastic.
I'm going to send you an envelope to
your address so you could kind of give me
the key. And he's like, yeah, yeah. Great,
great, great. How about like 600 bucks?
Oh, I know. I was like, Bro, Haim,
we just bonded over the fact
that I own both of your cars.
What are you doing to me here?
660 and remember like, you know,
to a lot of people that's nothing but
like to me like I was trying to be cheap
and scrappy. So tons of buses. 600 bucks.
Yeah, that's a bit much. A lot of money.
And I was like, Hey, I
was like, you didn't,
the key didn't exist to you as
of a week ago, but now the are,
you can make money from it.
Like,
now you wanna charge 100 bucks and he's
just like, you know, Da da Da. She said,
been talking again. And he goes,
how about 400 bucks? And I was like,
you know what guys,
I'll just give you the money.
Take the damn money and blood money.
Yeah, right. Exactly right. So I sold,
I sold my soul pretty much. And he did.
Yeah, he's got that blood money. No,
but I shouldn't have. I feel like
I was, I shouldn't have taken it.
I would've rubbed that money on
my balls. Hello? Y'all go bro.
Make sure you sniff that hundred dollar
bill first. I mean, it's like I get,
he's just being a dirt bag. Right? But no,
but after that you got the key and it's,
it's, that's what it is. And then
the car's running and driving today.
So as soon as you got the
key, you're good. Do you have
one key or two? Just one.
Oh, if I lose that, I'm screwed. Can
you make a phone? We're like your APP.
Does it work on the car? Nope. Damn. No,
that's big. The APP. That's huge. Yeah,
I always cool. Then you'll get the car to
come to you. You could sum it up. Yeah,
he can park like, like literally within
an inch on each side. Right. That's the,
that's the, that's the problem is that
I feel like with the, with the tasks,
because I have a model x now, so I have
the SUV now and it's the ultimate flex.
Tiffany Haddish had one and she had it
in the parking lot at the comedy store
and she had it dancing.
Really omen that door's kind of go
up and down and stuff to the music.
It just out in front of the
car and her and I answered it.
Everybody's dancing and they're
filming it. It was a hilarious moment.
And it's funny cause I,
I found myself,
I feel like this car has
ruined me as a person. Right.
Like I'm at typically like pretty humble
person, but like having like a Tesla.
The fact that you could push a
button and the car comes to you.
It's like the biggest, like
it's, it's a douchebag. No.
Because honestly we were doing,
we were like getting into our cars,
like peasants for years,
you know,
and one thing was at the gym and I was
looking at my car from, you know, from a,
you know, from a distance and
I was like, you know what?
I really don't feel like walking
all the way to my car today.
How far it was probably like
the distance from you to me.
It wasn't really that far.
It's like,
it was like the last thing between
us and I was like, you know what?
Come to Daddy, come to Daddy, pushed
a button. The car just backed out.
Everyone's like, Whoa, that car's driving
itself. I was like, yeah, that's me.
Push the button, open the door,
got in. I just drove off. Yeah.
When I take it and I put it in auto drive,
that's when it really freaks me out.
Yeah. You use that often.
Doesn't scare me, Finn. Yeah,
it scares me. It scares me,
but I keep my hands right there. But it
is freaky hasn't tried to kill you yet?
No. Okay. This is becoming really,
I'm just joking. Just joking. No,
it's like I'll just keep my hand there.
I always keep my hand there, but um,
I'm always,
the one thing I'm concerned with is
that I think I'm lowering my guard. Yes,
absolutely. I'm letting the car I'll do
too much. Absolutely. When you drive,
like one of the reasons for road
rage is when we're driving around,
we don't know who the fuck's next to
us and we were going very fast and it
requires the ability to
think really quickly.
So your brain is in a heightened state
of awareness and then someone does
something stupid like this
mother fucker. Right, exactly.
That's where the rage comes from.
But it, it lightens that almost.
Maybe too much.
Cause I think you do need to be what
she's kind of turned into my lane. Right.
I think you do need to be at least aware
that some shit can happen at any moment
when cars are flying by,
you go to 75 so you don't take your hands
fully off the car drive itself. Really?
Yeah. I just put my hand on it. I don't
take my hands fully off. But if you do,
you can only do it for so long.
And I'll start to warn them to complain.
Complaint be like, Hey,
what's going on here buddy?
But apparently some dudes tried.
They say that didn't work.
I talked to one of those dudes
who did that, that experiment.
Apparently that experiment
didn't, whatever orange. Yeah,
I think I might work man.
I think what does work better is
like they said, I like a lightweight,
like if you take like a,
like a lightweight and put it on like a
rubber band and you hang it. There was,
you know what's funny,
there was a guy that was selling that you
hear about that he was selling like it
looked like a,
uh,
it was like a basically like a weight
that went around the steering wheel and it
actually had the perfect amount of weight
balance and make you think that your
hand was still on the wheel. People
were buying it. There it is. And Tesla,
autoplay buddy. Hi Buddy. As Mag
relaunches has a phone mount. Yeah.
So then so, so, so we had that right.
He was selling it and it was like
300 bucks and then, you know,
they were like, that's
illegal. You can't do that.
You're bypassing like a
safety device of the car.
So then what he did was he came back
again with a vengeance and made it a phone
mount. He's clever. He's clever.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a smart move.
Although I'm not sure I support it. I
don't think I do either. That's kind of,
that's a little bit much. Don't think
it's ready for that. Weirds me out.
It weirds me out because the other
thing is the other people are,
are not going with auto drive.
So you're around,
you're going auto drive and all these
other people are just driving. Yeah.
And I think when everyone's
driving together,
you're kind of in tune with each other.
All this hassle was trying
to go really fast. Right.
Get the fuck over taking
this guy. Right. Yeah.
Let me pass this gate you were
aware of when you're just,
when you're auto driving, it's
like, you're like, like, uh,
assist in this moving.
Yeah.
That ecosystem thinking,
right.
All these people be
calculating each other.
But it's probably ultimately
like if you talk, talk to Ilan,
he says it's way safer
and then it's the future.
I hundred percent agree with them.
Absolutely. Obviously hates fun. Yeah.
Cause what would you do that don't forget.
Right.
Ilan could talk all this shit he wants.
Remember he had a Mclaren f one?
Yes he did. And he still has a Jaguar
e type one of those really old ones.
Like a 69 with the long Sharknado Long
Hood. Yep. Yeah. He's, he had a McLaren.
So he at heart, he knows the
deal. You know what I mean?
But he didn't make that car that fast for
a practicality. No, it makes no sense.
It's the same reason he made a fucking
blow torch. Exactly. Right. Right.
It's a silly person, I guess. Not a
flame thrower. We know that. It's not.
Definitely not a flame thrower.
Silly. Super Genius. So it is,
what do you think and all the best
ways. Yes. Right. Only good ways.
I'd never say anything bad about him
of the guy. He's so glad he's alive.
I am. I'm glad he's a real thing. No.
Honestly I and I understand degree.
I get a lot of crap from people online
saying I come and Eli Musk hater.
I'm a Tesla hater. Cause I could be
critical sometimes. You know what I mean?
But it's like the guys, the
guys a damn genius, but he's a
damn genius. Damn genius. And critical is
important guys. Like you are important.
It's very important to hear
what other people think.
If it's rezoned an intelligent right.
I get helps you even if you
don't like hearing it. All
right. So I've got to keep,
I mean he's a genius, but sometimes
you got to keep the company in check.
The cars are phenomenal cars.
They're phenomenal cars and
they weren't always, no,
absolutely not. Yeah. And what they
were, when they first came out,
like were you aware of the whole thing
with top gear? Yes. That was crazy. Yeah.
They were being shady.
Yeah. Super Shady. Yeah,
they were running the countdown car died.
They want it to bash the car much as
they could. But like for stuff like that,
like I'll stick up and say, Yo, hey,
you can't keep doing that. And He,
when he got pissed, he loves it. That's
his baby. Yeah, he sues the baby.
I think he lost because I think the way
there's show is structured that was,
it's interesting,
it's entertainment.
It's incredibly damaging to absolutely
company because it made it look like,
I don't know why they did that.
There's a couple of things that they
did the top gear did, but I was like,
why would you do that? Right. But that
was a sound of, some people remember they,
their, their focus focuses on petrol
or gas powered cars. Like when a,
when an eevee comes along
and it's actually pretty damn
good. And a lot of cases,
people are just like, Shit,
you can't let this thing win.
Especially back back in the
day when that was going on,
and that was a long time ago. That
was in 2012 I think. Yeah. 2013 yeah.
So you get the key from this guy's car,
right? You can't use the APP. Right.
So you, you have to rely on the
software and the state that it's at.
There's no software updates. No. So
here's the, here's the long story.
So get the cargo and everything's great
in order to get mask mask from the Tesla
system.
So there's a certain system that the
Tesla knows we're all their cars are and
they could disable whatever they want.
They can do whatever they want.
They see shut you down.
Exactly.
So I had to reach out to like this Tesla
black hat hacker pretty much. Oh Jesus.
He would go to the dark web.
I had to go to the deep dark web and um,
and he was able to mask
tousle from seeing the car,
which is why I can't have the
Tesla App. Oh. So he matched that.
So he got into the actual software
itself into the actual software itself.
Guy's a genius is Phil switched
one to zero. Exactly. Took the bit,
and then it was able to be,
uh,
the Cockettes supercharge the
car could do everything I can do.
And the car gets updates too. It's great.
Oh, it does. It does get updates. Yeah.
And Tesla doesn't know it's getting
updates. No. You know what's funny?
You shouldn't say this. I'm just kidding.
Now they, they know the deal. And here's,
here's a problem with that is that,
um, people love these cars a lot, man.
Yeah. I love these cars, you know, hence
me, I'm picking the car like a dirty lake,
you know what I mean? And fixing this
thing, you know what I mean? So it's,
it's a lot of the times it's in their
best interest I believe to help people out
a little bit. Yeah. Um, but, but no,
the things that people go through for
these cards is insane and people just,
they just love them.
They're my,
my take on it is that what they have
is this ingenious company with this mad
genius scientist who's running it,
who does a million other
things at the same time. Right.
And they don't have enough people
to deal with someone like you.
They probably just don't,
they don't have like a section of the
company to deal with someone like you.
They, do you remember when
he was working, when he was,
they were trying to put out the model
three and he was working 16 hours a day
and sleeping on the floor of the category.
Pretty much.
Shit that don't make any sense. Like
what the people know. It's funny people,
it doesn't make any sense, but people
love the company. They love this guy. So,
so Cigna that um,
when he was working 16 hours a day and
he was sleeping on the floor in the
factory, right? You know,
it was a big sob story,
a billion to be on the full the factory.
A bunch of Tesla owners rallied together
and they purchased a couch for him to
sleep on like tens of thousands
of dollars. What kind of couches?
I must been a nice ass count.
Crazy. But either way, like they,
they rallied and they purchase a couch for
him. And like I made a video. I didn't,
I said to myself, you know what?
This guy's a billionaire B.
But the fact that everyone
rallied together to help
this guy to show that their
support people are hands over fist
with his company, man, they are heels.
It reminds me of apple back in the day.
You know,
I remember there was a, God,
God bless his heart who uh,
was one of the editors on news radio was
a sitcom that it was on in the 90s and
he was such an apple head
that he was like, he,
he was talking about it like
it was a sports team. He
was talking about it. Well,
I think we're really going to get those
PC guys routine when the Mac books come
out. I keep, but he really said
something to that all along those lines.
I think we're really gonna
pull ahead. Like who's we?
We mean we're only doing me.
Yeah, they were on this weird little
tribe. Mac and this is the same thing,
but you know what?
You don't picture the apple fanboys,
the Tusla fanboys times 10 and they live
in it. It's like an apple. You live in,
it's, you know, times 10.
Because I've been at work because not
because apple has the technology aspect of
it. Like it's great. You
know, android socks, I have
an apple phone. Okay, perfect.
Perfect. But for Teslas, you're
talking about technology.
So you have a tech nerds,
you're talking about sustainability
as well. For the green people, Green.
So you have the tech and the green
people and once they joined forces the
scariest force on the earth. Right. It
isn't like war, like guns and stuff.
It's actually a Mac
owning Tesla vegan owner.
That's the scariest thing in the way.
It really is a scary thing in the world
because they'll tell you all about it at
a party. Oh my God. It cornered, they
get corner. But like they, it and it's,
and I've struggled with that a lot and
a lot of cases because whenever I say
something remotely negative
about Tessa, like, Hey,
I think Tesla could do a better job here.
They're just like,
you're just a gas head. I know you own
a zero six you worked for big, what?
Someone acuity working for big oil.
Oh, you do? Yeah. What do you do?
How do you work from the coil? What does
that mean? You work for big oil. Yeah.
You A, you're a part of the
Illuminati. Yeah, pretty much.
That's like I just, yeah,
she worked for big oil for big oil.
What does that mean?
Does that mean how much could
they pay you to, first of all,
before people would realize it,
all of a sudden you're walking
around with like diamond
chain be moved to a giant mansion.
Right? He's still fixing cars.
Do you have a big oil law? You know, I've
got another thing going on. Right, right.
I'm making billions for big oil by, by
a gas car. Go to shell. Shell's Great.
I don't understand how people think
that that whole shill thing works.
Then you just get like a monthly check.
I don't understand. Like, hey rich,
say something negative about tests.
Every once in a while we'll give you a
check for 23 they get to get that big oil
check.
I suspect that what it is is similar to
what my friend who was really addicted
to apple. I think you just get on
your tribe and that's my thing.
I'm all about apple and that's
your camp windows or it's bullshit.
When does this bull shoe you want to play?
What are you going to fuck
with the config files?
Get in there and then use dos and get
out of here. Yeah, you lose it a loser.
But it's interesting cause people like
us are very different because we could
appreciate both if you have a phenomenal
collection of cars. Thank you. And um,
and then you, you threw a Tusla
in there, but you love both. Yeah.
If you love the driving,
you'd left the driving aspect of it.
You have your Porsche, you know, you love,
you know the, the, the silence and the,
the zero to 60 of your Tesla too.
So like you could,
we could be part of both camps, but a lot
of cases they're only, it's camp Tesla.
And if you're not with us,
you're against us. Silly. Yeah.
I have a windows laptop and I have an
apple laptop. Oh you do? Yeah. Jeez.
I both really, yeah. You know why?
Cause windows has more options
and when you have more options,
you get better configurations.
You get better keyboards. Like A,
I have a Lenovo thinkpad. Oh look
at you dude. They're the shit. Yeah.
It's way better to write on like the
tactile feedback and the travel distance
and the keys is so much longer. Right.
You just know where you're typing it.
For me as a writer, when I'm writing, I'm
writing standard or something like that,
it requires less thinking. Right. Cause
my fingers just find the keys easier.
I mean like 10% plus easier.
It's a big deal.
And I bought an older apple laptop too.
I bought a 2015 a refurbished one cause
their keyboards were superior. Yes.
The new ones are so low profile
the type, anything. Absolutely.
It's the shittiest fucking keyboard
of any computer that you can buy.
Today is a new Mac book pro and they
got busted for that because now because
their keyboards are so shitty,
if it takes them back now,
they didn't recalls in the keyboard.
While they do have a new patent they
put out for a variable height keyboard
where the key travel will vary and the
key resistance will. Very interesting.
Yeah.
This is a new patent that they filed for.
It doesn't necessarily mean they even
have the technology for it. Right.
That sounds expensive.
I don't know why.
If it's something that you could press
a button that just raises the keys up,
that would be like a solution.
Because if you think about
the flatness of the key,
the idea is they want to keep a low
profile to this laptop or and make it thin
and sexy, which is like fucking whatever
the, I don't have the think pad with me,
but I have a the x one carbon.
It's sad. Those are nice.
Right? And the battery life is
excellent. Six months, dude.
It's a fucking great laptop.
Right? So apple just,
they're just only apple and the problem
with that one company only selling
laptops is you just don't
have enough variety.
There's not enough people that
are offering challenges to it.
They don't have any challenges.
In fact,
their biggest challenge
is the waterway mate book.
Huawei basically stole their, their
idea and but made it way better. Right?
They made, oh, I see what you guys
are doing. You guys are fucking up.
We're going to be doing it the same way.
We're going to make it with better keys.
Right? We're going to have no
bezels on the side of the screen.
And you know everyone's
concerned about security.
Well we're just going to have the Webcam
pop up as a key. Have you seen that? No,
I have it. No Dope. That
sounds next level shit.
I want to see why way am I saying that
right? That's it. Come on Bro. Oh Shit.
That's dope as fuck. Look
no bezels. No bezels. No,
no room for the Webcam and it
has great keyboard travel too.
I think it's like 1.5
millimeter key travel,
which is if you are a person
who writes all the time,
I need to get my thoughts out. I'm
stupid. Do you write a lot? Write a lot.
Stand up. And I just write things and
extract. Stand up from them and right,
but when I write I want, I don't
need to be fucking with the keys man.
So why do you use your Mac then you,
this is all these pros about the,
about the PC.
But why do you have to have both?
I use that when I travel cause I
don't write as much when I travel.
But I like to watch movies. And you
looked at that pops up. How about that?
That's the f six gears. It looks right
up, you know son, that's pretty wild.
But that's good because of
weird because it's a profile.
But the biggest thing is like when you're,
you,
you probably have like a Skype meetings
or whatever. Google hangouts. Uh,
the worst thing in the world is like the
camera turning on automatically death.
A lie right there. That image is a lie.
That is not what it was. No one. Yeah, no,
that's him the fuck out. It's impossible.
Even the right viewpoint. Yeah.
That's ridiculous. No one's that good
looking either. She's pretty hot. Yeah.
Yeah. But it does pop up, man.
That's in state. So that's,
that's a thing because it was just like
a Mac. Yup. It looks just like a Mac,
except it is more key travel,
more comfortable and that upper
right hand corner, that power.
But he was also a fingerprint reader. Oh
fuck it. I'm going to buy one right now.
They're the shit. I would, I would
use one. But you don't have one? No.
When did I have? Oh yeah. Yeah. It's
great to never did. I mean, this is just,
they're there. It's all
just better options. Right.
The only difference is windows is not as
good as macro s but it's not that much
worse. No, it's really not.
It's pretty fucking close.
Windows 10 is pretty fucking good.
And see what this run,
what does it run on windows? There's
some windows. Windows, windows, windows,
windows 10 yeah. She was not android.
No, that's a good one. That day. Right?
It would have to be one of
those Chromebooks. Right.
It was going to run android,
which apparently is very good tone. Book
designs are really nice too. Very nice.
Nice. And you can get
one super cheap. Right.
And the battery lasts like three months.
That's forever.
And if you just putting documents,
he put them into your
Google docs in the cloud,
you pull it up instantaneously
drive. No, it's great. Yeah. But why?
Why is a weird company man like I
don't know what I feel about, I'm,
I'm buying into all this government
propaganda about the Chinese spying on us.
Yeah. It's definitely spying
on your fat. Well Dude,
I've had my credit card stolen. My number
stolen three times this year. Why? How?
It's never happened to me. Yeah. Well I
think, I think the more money you have,
the more stuff you could still
maybe, yeah, maybe people find out.
It's annoying though.
Like I got a charge,
but I have an app on my phone that
shows me the charge and it was during a
podcast while I'm like, well that
definitely wasn't me. Yeah, no,
definitely was they get you with like
$10 one. So cool. $3, $10 a test.
The waters to start.
Quad microphones accurately pick up sound
from four meters away with the wall.
Wait, what is that really spying on you?
But yeah, they did it. What? They're not,
what they're not telling you is that
the microphones are always active.
I was this dog. Yeah. Just like your
phone. They're always listening again.
The government bro Translate Multiple Epp
people. Oh, great. Microsoft translator.
You hear about the new TVs,
you hear about the, uh, the,
the LG TVs that was spying on constantly
listening conversation. Wonderful.
And they told you if you want to have
a private, confidential conversation,
don't have it in front of the TV
who they were basically saying,
what if you're bring your wife in front
of the TV? That's interesting. Yeah.
Does it have cameras on them?
Yeah, they have a camera.
I think it live streams that I think
it's like a sex mode. After a while.
Everyone's just going to watch
everybody do everything. I really,
I really think within a hundred
years that's going to be the case.
That's the case now, man. I think it's
going to bloggers and like, you know, I'm,
I'm on, I'm on Youtube. You know how that
goes and everyone wants to see what, Oh,
what are you doing now? What are you
doing now? I didn't get a video last week.
What's going on? What are you doing
now? Yeah. You know, it's, it's,
but what we accept is way different
than what our parents accepted or would
their parents accepted.
And I think what our children except is
going to be weighing different and then
what their children, except it's
going to be, we're like two,
three generations from it just being
ridiculous where there's no privacy.
How do you distance yourself because
you're a public figure, right?
How do you distance yourself? Like
where do you draw the line for privacy?
I guess you could say the real
problem was when you're eating man,
when people like come up
to you while you have,
like I'll have a kid in my lap and I'll
be eating food and talking to the kid
and someone will literally come up to
me and tried to take a picture of me,
asked me to take a picture
with me. I'm like, come on man,
we're all out eating at a restaurant.
Like this is like, you know, just say hi.
Just say hi man. And I always tell
people when I'm done and I'm leaving,
I'll take a picture with you. But you
can't, you can't just interrupt dinner.
That's insane.
But it's just,
it's just people think like if they
don't get a picture with you right now,
you can get it right now. Now, now,
now fucking don't care. I'm going in.
I'm an average cook. Right. And they don't
care. I mean, and then they'll say, hey,
that's the price you pay for being famous.
Well now it's like, no, come on guys.
That's, it's crazy. Like this is the deal.
The deal is some provides
something that you enjoy,
whether it's stand up or a thing
and I appreciate that you enjoy it,
but that's our exchange. All
the other stuff. Anything else?
Meeting me at a restaurant and shit
when a, when I'm eating with my kid,
like come on man. That's the, you're
asking for too much. This is a ridiculous,
here's another question for you.
What kind of restaurants you eat at
where people feel need to come up?
Td at like a high end, right? Like apple
bees and stuff or like no Wednesday
math. Right. Mostly places.
Normal normal spots. It's not,
it's not normal that someone does that.
Most people were super respectful,
but all it takes is one out of a
hundred and then it just gets weird.
And most people don't.
Most people are cool,
but it's every now and then people just
have this idea that somehow or another
you have to, if you are a famous person,
you have to abandon everything, right?
Just to Pr. That's the other thing that
you're not a person anymore, right?
You're like a famous person. Like it's
like the regular rules don't apply to him.
Someone don't apply.
Like you would never just barge in on
a regular person that you did. No, no.
But if it's a regular famous person,
people, they don't give a fuck off.
This is fine. Whatever. Right? Where your,
you and your friend are both crying
and talk about someone who died.
You don't give a fuck. Hey Man, I'm sorry
to interrupt bro. But I get that picture,
Bro. Damn. Can I get that picture, Bro?
So what's the weirdest interaction
you've had with someone?
It's mostly just that kind of stuff.
You're the shit is like people that
tell me that they're going to give me
secrets like Ufo type stuff, big
foot. And I know where the bases are.
Like really those
motherfuckers. Yes. Ghettos.
I've had a few of those restaurants
just walking on the street.
Usually a comedy shows. Yeah.
Yeah. Usually a comedy shows.
Do you ever walk down the street?
That's what weird thing I just asked you.
I mean, cause like when you're always
either driving, you're going somewhere.
You ever go for a casual walk around
at well I do. I walked my dog. Right.
But yeah, I don't walk
around La. Nobody does.
Nobody walks in pockets of walking
in La. So time out. Real quick,
real quick. Quick story with time with
rich. So I landed right. And you know,
you know Boston and the deal in Boston.
Yeah. Uh, so I landed and you know, I uh,
a buddy of mine picked me up from the
airport and I got to where I was staying
on staying in the mission district.
Look at all the sudden, first of all,
it was freaking great. The Sun was
awesome. Right. I was looking at, my gosh,
Sung gray skies and then I looked down
literally homeless people everywhere and
what is going on with that?
Like it just,
it blew my mind because it literally,
so I went to the gym in
the morning and I was like,
it was like at 7:00 AM and I saw probably
just as many homeless people living in
tents next to buildings as there
were people commuting to work. Yeah,
like thousand. Oh yeah. It's,
it's amazing. Have you been
in skid row yet? No. God,
I'm scared.
You got to go.
You should go while you're here
because it's like the Grand Canyon,
like the Grand Canyon of homeless people.
Why would I want to go there?
Because it's just, you can't
believe that. It's like,
did you watch the battle of
Winterfell game of Thrones? No.
Don't tell no spoilers. No,
I won't give any spoilers.
I'll have to have come with a better.
Okay. Here's a better analogy.
Did you ever see a I am legend.
Okay.
Remember when all the fucking crazy
Zombie people running at once. Yeah.
That's what it's like. Are
you serious? I'm telling you,
you can't believe the volume
doesn't someone even like,
because in Boston, listen,
I'm a freeze to death and
die. Yeah, exactly. So No,
in Boston we, we hide our homeless
people. We have like shelters and stuff,
we hide them for the most part, you know,
downtown crossing area, parks sheet,
whatever. They like the junkies that
like have that, the whole gangster lean,
they just lean, close their eyes and they
must fight. Right. And then we, you know,
it gets cold, they scattered.
I don't know where they go,
but you don't really see them that
much. You know, I'm not being rude.
Like I don't mind her saying it's great,
but like in say,
but they're in your face,
man. Like you, I've,
if San Francisco is the craziest,
it's, it was insane. So like, honestly,
and then one of my friends, he said,
listen, you know, I'm coming to my house,
you know, whatever. We're going to hang
out for a beer at school. No problem.
Went to his house like a small place,
not batting a thousand square feet.
I'm like, pretty nice. He goes,
yeah, you know, I'm Kinda, you know,
things are a little tough. Can I,
you know, can I borrow some, uh,
some money was like borrow money from me,
but he talking about do this is you
live in, you know, you're doing okay.
He's like, yeah, we're living
paycheck to paycheck. I was like,
what are we talking about? I'm like,
this is a, this is like a, you know,
you had a decent place.
The house we were in was a one point $6
million house and it was this big and
I'm like San Francisco, so stupid
is expensive man. And said, listen,
Hey, come to my house, you know, and I
pull up to the house. It's a warehouse.
Like they live in a warehouse that's
actually cool. You can live like blade.
It's snipes lives with Kris
Kristofferson. It's, yeah,
you're right. You're right. He had the
motorcycle, he had the fucking charger,
dodge charger. But it sounds cool when
you have kids living in a warehouse.
Isn't that great?
So that's the thing is that like,
it's a common thing I've noticed for
people to live in either abandoned
buildings, warehouses
and cars. Yeah. You know,
people that live in cars and the amount
of smashed windows that I've seen here,
it's, I couldn't believe it. Well,
most of those people live in cars
are actually stand up comedians.
Everybody has a fucking story.
Like so many comics come
here and before, you know,
when they first settled in,
they live in the car. That's
super normal. Yeah. That's,
that's it. Just crazy. Like models.
10 of my friends really lived in
their car and go to live in cars.
They're used to at least and then
got an apartment, bigger car. Uh,
that's an issue we're having around here.
We're having around here with
these people that live in caravans.
They live in these mobile home things.
I've seen the mass, there's like,
if you drive around this community,
go down certain streets and you just
see these massive caravans. Yeah.
And they have like, like towels over the
windows. And I saw the math and science.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. These are
dirge people. Some of these
fuckers, I don't. So how come?
So again, in Boston we just
kind of say, hey, you got this.
No likely in a loitering where they're
kicking people out now because businesses
are complaining.
Because there was one business where
this guy had parked his caravan right in
front of it.
That's where a buddy of mine works and
this dude had laid out is like a blanket
on their front lawn and was sunning
himself. One of his caravan,
the front of his building
became this guy's lawn.
So this guy in this caravan was literally
using the, that we're sharing grass,
right? So he's got this multimillion
dollar building and he's sharing it with a
homeless guy who's cooking meth
or I don't know if it's math,
but some white noxious
smoke that comes out place.
I couldn't. So it, it's, it was
different for me. The weather is awesome,
but like that was a big thing.
And I feel
like as I'm walking around more,
if I see a large standing body of water,
I'm like there's a homeless
guy live in there too,
that people just everywhere
they're everywhere.
I'm telling you what you saw is nothing.
When you got to go to skid row,
it's what is, this is a skid row, skid
row. This is Google maps. It's good real.
I just started snooping around. They
must've cleaned it up right before. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Let me know. Shit,
that ain't shit. Let me tell
you something, man. It's,
look at that. Look at all that to the
right and to the left. It's fucking gross.
So how do people have businesses there?
They don't or they just deal with it.
They just deal with it.
Most of them,
most of those people that just put
all like gates and locks and shit.
What's on skid row? It's can you where
you just were Jamie? We just were,
um, well it's a lot of
warehouses and shit and,
but the interesting thing is this
area is getting air quotes gentrified.
So this where a lot of
businesses are going now.
They're opening up apartment buildings
and a buddy of mine has lived there.
My friend Magnus Magnus Walker,
he's a famous car guy too.
I don't know if you know who he is.
He's got all these videos of
Porsche's or he rebuilt old Porsches.
He's got this crazy dreadlocks
and beard and crazy Englishman,
but he's been living down there
forever. He, and he has a,
this warehouse where he has it set up
where, you know his living spaces, one,
one part of the warehouse and then
down below Jase these cars. Right?
And he has it all set up.
But if you drive down some of these roads,
you'll see like the super expensive
apartment buildings that are going up now.
And then a block over,
you'll see these homeless encampments
and people think it's like cute to be
around like all this dirt. What does this,
there we go. Nice. Look, now look at that.
So that's someone's apartment. It's going
on here? Yeah, they're just set up tents.
And then the cops kicked them out and
they just come back and they move and then
they come back. But they, they make
these encampments and you just,
you just have to deal with it. So it's
like if you live in that area, you know,
you just have to jump over needles
and try to figure your way.
I felt so I feel terrible because
no, it's, it's most of this.
Most of this is either drug addiction
or mental illness. Those are the real,
real problem.
All right.
Do you guys have no drug addiction or
mental illness like places that you could
go to for help here? I don't know what
it is, man. I don't know enough about it.
Entirely ignorant about
how what's going on.
I know that if you talk to people that
work in the field that work with these
folks, they say that it all really started
to happen. Look at this guy. He's like,
run over my leg. Oh my gosh. And I
need disability. Oh my goodness man.
That's crazy. Crazy there on the
street. This is like, honestly,
if you were to take a screenshot, what
you just showed me, I'd be like, okay,
that's some third world country.
This is la.
People can't even afford to live in La.
I know.
I might as well be a third
world country though.
I mean it might as well be the apocalypse.
It's the apocalypse for those folks.
I mean at least there they're
around all these cars and shit,
but I mean there are thousands of homeless
people and that whole skid row area
right next to the mission there.
Yes. That's one of the reasons.
One of the things that keeps them
there, I guess. Mission beds,
three beds and the whole thing.
I don't know. That's wild.
Now they'll allow most of this to
go on. I don't know. Like how often
they break it up and make people move,
but this did not, the numbers are so
high. There's not much they can do. Man.
That's crazy. It's sad, sad.
It's Super Sad. But what do
you do? How do you fix that?
Like I don't have any solution. I mean
you can't tell people they shouldn't.
We do it. What does that say? Documentary.
Remember documentary? Yeah. Yeah. Pros.
And then went and spent three days down
there like undercover and filming him,
experiencing it and then he'd come back
and do like an interview or like what
you just went through and it's, it came
out 10 years ago. So it's, it's different.
I don't know if I'm, I'm assuming it's
worse now, but it's definitely not good.
And this and this, so many. It's crazy.
So, uh, I, I was in my one wheel, right?
Just rec riding by, I was commuting
back and by the way, the thing is bad.
It's pretty crazy, right? Yeah. I've wrote
it. I wrote yours today. He did ride mine.
It was good. And after watching you
scoot around effortlessly, I was like,
how hard could it be? Do you
need one? You should get one.
I also don't need broken
elbows like Odyssey. It's good
for, it's good. It's good.
It's a good core workout. It's
a great word. You sit ups,
I think it's a better core workout,
but sit up and she'll show you this hip
and gluten machine from rogue where you
put your ankles in this thing
and you lean all the way back.
And go all the way up to then you have
some next level shit here by the way.
Thank you. Some cool stuff, man. That's
awesome man. Warehouse. It's really,
it's this place is fucked. Can I live
here? Sure. Alright, cool. Plenty of room.
Bring it. 10 kept out of the
Jitsu bats. Um, but, but yeah,
so I was right. My one wheel,
uh, pass this, uh, past like
this is kind of overpass.
And uh,
there was a tent there and like a,
a lady sticks her hand out and
she offers me a chocolate. Uh,
what was it? I think it was a,
a chocolate lady bug, right?
It was a lady bug wrapped
in like that, that, that,
that tin chocolate whenever I'm like,
oh. I'm like, no thank you. No thank you.
Right back again. The next day offered
to me again. I was like, no thank you.
No thank you. I was like, you know what?
I'm going to, I'm going to like, you know,
do something nice. Right? So I get
five bucks and I was like, I'll go,
I'll give it to her. You know, it's
a nice gesture. I write up, you know,
I give her a hand to the five bucks. Uh,
as I start slowing down the one wheel,
other people started popping their heads
out of the tents and they actually saw
me give her the money and immediately
a guy runs out and like snatches it
directly out of our hand,
snatched it right at hand.
Someone else comes around the corner,
takes it from him,
and they start getting into the scuffle.
And I'm just like,
I've never seen anything like that before.
I know I'm really passionate
about that. I just, it's just,
I just can't stop thinking about it. It's
crazy. It's really crazy out here, man.
It's crazy. And everyone comes,
everyone comes to to, to La,
California to get their big
break. Like, Oh, I'll let him,
I'm going to be like a famous whatever
famous, you know, actor, a singer,
exotic dancer, a porn star, whatever.
And it's, the struggle is real out here.
It's real. It's real everywhere. But when
whenever you get giant groups of people,
you're going to get,
you know,
a higher percentage of people that are
out here that are homeless or struggling.
Right. Um, again, I don't know
what the fuck. Oh, well what's
the solution? Yeah, no idea.
I know they don't put enough effort
into it and then just whatever,
whatever the solution is.
That's one of the arguments that who
was it someone made? Was it Cher?
Someone unlikely had a really
good argument like that.
Everybody is so concerned about illegal
aliens getting into this country and so
not concerned about our homeless problem.
Right. And what the fuck is that about?
Like there's people right here right
now and neither were not taken care of.
Right. And you're like, but these people
from other countries, they're trying to,
oh,
but which I might take on that though is,
but those people were trying to do
better. They just got fucked. Right.
Where's the other people live in America.
Okay. That's too many events. It's share.
Look at her.
Yeah.
That's what happens when old ladies still
look that good time, Bro. This year.
She's 12
she went back in time.
If my state kit, first of all,
this is my problem, right?
Why is this bitch capitalizing
every word? Oh, that's frustrating.
Oh my God.
She's capitalizing all of them and then
afterwards she's capitalizing those
letters.
If capital m y capital s t
a t like someone to write
this for her on her safety.
Must be, she's got an assistant.
She's got an assist him.
He hates her and she's like, I'm a subtly
going to make this pitch looks too,
I'm tired of her fake pictures and
their Photoshop filters. Fuck you share.
Can we, Hey, can we just for the
hell that can we find like a,
a recent photo of share?
Like how old is share?
Actually 750 I would say she's
65 how old do you think she is?
We'll take guest share homes.
How old are you?
60 [inaudible] 72 damn.
She about to turn 73 and was serious
when I was a kid. Well, it makes sense,
man. I'm 51 she does. I was a kid
like 20 years ago or yesterday.
You asshole way. You're, you're, is that,
what is that what money does? That's a
vampire facial. That's what money does.
I got to get some money. Yeah, you got to
get that money. The money gets you good.
Google search pictures.
All the keys. Oh Wow.
That's legit. But that's what they
sound like when they get to that age.
They start talking crazy. Sent her real
hair. Oh, 100% yeah. She bought it.
She bought, she owns it. She does own
that here. Yes. Good man. She's good.
She looks good. She married.
You want to know? I do not.
I don't know why I asked that.
That was a, we have enough.
That's what the movie is like, you know,
really get her to sign. No prenup. Right.
How much time Shan Ching,
Cha Ching. I mean if you can
hang in there for 20 years,
what are the odds that she can too?
I got wait it out.
Wait it out man. That's awful for her.
This is announcing our tour this year.
This picture photo.
Yeah.
Fuck it is that people use my
old pictures from my Twitter.
I don't even ask them
to do. Just if you find
that picture of me against a brick wall.
We took that shit back in the old studio.
That picture was like four years old.
Yeah. She's um, she's on tour.
Congratulations. Good for her.
We were talking about vampire
facials that some ladies, uh,
Jeff told us this lady, two people
got HIV and AIDS, right? Yeah.
Not necessarily eight. Sorry.
I jumped the gun. I know.
I jumped the gun and it's more fun to say
I have an HIV I apologize for with HIV.
I get this right now.
It's like,
he feels like you're not even supposed
to say aids. Like you can't say age.
Like whoa, whoa. Sensitive.
So down brother to test positive after
vampire facial says vampire facial is
girls get jabbed in the face
with some zip plasmas it.
What does it PRP, what do, what are they
doing? Didn't, didn't have that. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. She took pictures of
it on the INSTA. I don't understand.
Wait a minute. Don't they get a new
needle every time he used the same needle?
I don't want not hair. No. If there
you, there's Kim. Beautiful. Oh my God.
Awesome.
Um,
I don't know if they use other
people's blood for the facial watch.
Yeah,
I think that's probably what's going on.
I don't think instead it's a used needle.
I think it's that they're using
someone else's blood. Why would you,
this doesn't make any sense. It's like,
does this make sense to anyone? No,
because I would think that
that if you drew blood,
you would draw it from yourself.
It takes it from your body,
puts it in a centrifuge
and then put the right.
So that is basically platelet
rich plasma. So, but why,
why would anybody get HIV unless you're
giving it to yourself? Maybe they,
maybe they already had HIV banner lion
myth busted blaming it on Mexico wows per
usual. What did, why did she
do it? Her notes. She did it
on every part of her body.
But her nose. Yeah. She's scared of her
nose. She knows to look old plastic. Ah,
just kidding. Just kidding. Camp. You
will watch this. I'm just kidding.
Just kidding. Lol. Yeah. So what
happened to these fucking people?
Did they really use an old needle?
That doesn't mean they probably
already had aids. That's what it is.
God Damn Liar.
Because think about it for a second.
Why would you take an AIDS test before?
You know, Ooh, we're getting deep.
I took an ace test before and after my
facial and then I didn't even have a,
it's till after my facial.
Congratulations. Right? Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense.
That's like a, the Indian, uh, footage,
they found footprints of what they think
is big foot in India and people saying,
Hey asshole, this is an animal hopping.
Yeah. This thing's only got one leg.
If there's a big foot, it's
a one legged, big foot.
Like some doctor Seuss creature like
that. They're like, look stupid.
That's not two feet. It's not bipedal.
What do you guys do? Look at that.
That's one leg. Look at
that boring, boring bunk.
That's an animal jumping you assholes.
The thick part is where their butland's
the front part of their paws. Right?
Just keep going. See, you see one
of them. It's even broken up. Like,
look at that one picture where like
one of those footprints is actually two
separate marks in the, in the snow.
I'm not even a wildlife biologist.
The one right there, I'm not
even a wildlife biologist.
Rabbit Bro. It's a rabbit.
Those are kind of big be a rabbit body,
rabbit,
rabbit. There's some big ass
rabbits. How big the router,
Himalayas duty were scenes. I don't
know. That's what I'm wondering.
She a question to Himalayas, like what
would it be? What? What is your animal?
It could be,
well,
one of the things this is very interesting
about animals is that when they go
further north,
contrary to logic,
like what you would think they actually
get larger, you would think, well,
it's colder up there. They probably
get a small little thicker, but no,
they preserve their body temperature,
but being larger,
that's why Moose are so big.
They're the furthest north, uh,
of all the cows make sense to me.
Totally makes sense.
If you get a deer from Mexico,
they're tiny. They're like
a hundred pounds, right?
There's a deal, dear called the
coups deer and a really big one.
It's a hundred cows or coups depending
on who you ask. C O u s but it's a,
a variation of the whitetail
deer that's really small.
It only weighs like 100 pounds and it's
in Mexico full grown one. It's like a,
like a dog size. And then there's other
ones that are in like Saskatchewan,
that same species that are 300 pounds.
How do you know so much about deers?
Because I killed them all. Your
a Ha, I forgot you were out.
That explains the giant bowl outside.
Yeah. That's how I get my meat.
Nups please.
You know what?
A supermarket like everyone else
had to go to supermarket. But most,
most of the meat that I eat,
I try to eat from animals that I kill.
Where do you hunt? In La? No, La is
tricky. The tents get in the way.
Your Line of sight,
the lineup,
but you can get a lot of coyote hunting
in La if you want this fucking coyote
everywhere out here, man. What
you eat a coyote from la? Uh,
I don't think I'd eat a coyote period.
Right? Yeah. Unless there was a goof.
Uh, or I was really hungry.
You can eat them though. I
mean you can, it's just meat.
Yeah. You'd have to cook it really, really
well, but when you cut away all the,
the fur and mange and all the shit on
the outside left, just get a tissue.
Where do you,
uh,
where do you hunt typically the mountains
usually every year I go to Utah in the
mountains of Utah. What do you got
Jimmy further explanation on this.
Oh, it's a bear. Okay.
They call Yeti something different about
Himalayan Brown bear or a Tibetan blue
bear. Oh, what they call
with all due respect,
but we call Yeti is with all probability.
The either,
oh, no, no, no. Okay. Then it's not like
they called the Himalayan bear a Yeti.
It's like they're saying
that it was probably a bear
that was making those marks.
That makes sense.
If those are big marks that the
bear was hopping through the snow,
if it's thick snow, that's
a, that makes sense.
That Guy [inaudible] he's a nice guy.
With all due respect to everyone.
[inaudible] signal footprints or when
the bear walks on four feet. Yeah,
that makes sense. All right. Yeah, so
yeah, so as you go to Utah and you just,
you just wait, well there's
a lot of hiking, you know,
you go and you essentially you go where
you know that the elk are going to be in
the area and when they're in the Rut,
which is that when you hunt,
that's when it's legal,
which means they're their mating and
breeding and smashing heads together and
then you hear them,
you hear them scream at each other
and you're ready to be killed. Well,
they are definitely ready to
build them a little. Do they know?
Then you've got to figure
out how to sneak in on them,
but they can't help themselves.
They just,
they're competing with all these other
males screaming at each other and
smashing heads and occasionally you'll
find one that's dead that was killed by
another bull. But you don't eat that.
No, no, no, no. You could, I mean,
you certainly could if it was
like a recent kill, if you knew,
if you got to it like
right when it was dying,
it was the chair of the blood
was still coming out of its body.
But you will find them. They get stabbed
and they, they kill each other. Yeah.
That mean that's the whole reason
why those antlers exist for war.
They just fuck each other up.
They don't even use it to defend against
the other animals like wolves and shit.
They kicked the wolves most of the time.
So where do you,
how do you get the thing back?
Those things don't, aren't
light. Yeah, you have to,
uh, you have to do what's
called quartering it,
which is you take the legs off and you
take the front legs off and then you take
the meat off the carcass and then you
take the heart and the liver and the,
the edible organs and you have
to pack it out. So you have a,
you have a crew that goes with Iui or
is it just you with a big ass knife?
I bought. I'm not very
good at hunting. I'm like,
if hunting was a a martial art,
I'd be a blue belt.
Blue Bell is like your white belt, blue
belt, purple belt, Brown belt. Black Belt,
right? Oh, it's not a black
belt. I'm like a blue belt.
Maybe I could get my purple belt
if I look work real hard this year,
but I go with a guide who's going to take
me to the places that I need to go and
show me and a guy who is an experience
outdoorsman who basically teaches you.
It's like having a trainer in martial
arts. Exactly. It shows you, yeah, he's,
he knows the landscape is
a hardened outdoorsmen.
These guys never get fucking tired and
they'll go and take you and show you like
it, but then it's, it's your
job to execute the shot.
Your job to get close your job,
to stock in your job,
to make sure that you don't get what's
called winded means the animal smells you.
The wind's at your back and the wind
carries her sent towards the animal.
So you have to move around of thought
that goes into this. A lot of thoughts.
I don't use a gun. I used to be, oh, I'm
going to have used a gun. I have. Really?
Yeah. I shot a bow on it and it didn't
go so well. It just Kinda, it's fun.
Both just shooting targets is really fun.
It's very cathartic.
It says there's like something,
there's a release when that Arrow finds
his target just feels really good. Yeah,
it's probably some primitive shit from
back when we used to rely on killing
things with those scenarios
that like accuracy.
But there's something about
hitting something with a, uh,
like when you shooting something
at a target and hits it, it's very,
very satisfying. Rewarding. Yeah. And
when you do that with a bow and Arrow,
it's very difficult. It's more
challenging. It's more rewarding. Yeah.
I've never used a traditional,
but I mean I have like a couple of times,
but I've never really tried to shoot
with like a traditional bow or a gun.
But they also like that. No, no,
I have, uh, you draw it. I mean,
you would have to pull it back,
but it's a compound bow.
It relies on these mechanical,
uh, these gears that these, um,
what do they call camps?
It's like the Boeing walking dead and
we watched the one that's a crossbow.
The crossbow. Yeah. That's,
that's a bullshit though with
that is, is a shitty gun.
Okay. So this guy's got a trigger.
Any, well, let us zombies.
It would make me very angry. Very
frustrated. Okay. First of all,
it doesn't even have a broadhead
on that stupid thing. Right?
He's shooting them with a little pencil
holes and it's killing him instantly.
That's all. That's all he had
access to make a broad head makeup.
Brought him out to do that break into
a bass pro shop, have some projects,
you know? Yeah man, man, she did see
a few bass pro shops and walking dead.
They just walk right past their
brothers and nets and the kayaks.
Um, so that's a crossbow. And there's
a, that's a very controversial, uh,
weapon amongst outdoorsmen.
Why is that?
Because they use those during bow season.
Okay.
And there's a reason
why bow season like the,
if you looked at like
statistics across the board,
if you have a what's called a tag,
like say if you wanted to go deer hunting,
you'd have to get a license and then
you'd get a tag and if the tag was
available for the area, you wanted you
to pay a certain amount for that tag.
Now if you get a boat tag,
they,
they make the bow season earlier,
you have a higher,
a much higher likelihood of failure
with a bow than you do with a gun.
So I could say like 50% of the people that
got a tag, it's usually not that high.
But if 50% of the people that got
a tag for rifle were successful,
it might be 10% with a boat,
it might be even less.
It might be even less than some places,
depending on how rugged the landscape is,
how hard it is to get to
where the animals are.
And you have to be able to
shoot far accurately. Right.
So do you do most of the shooting
when you go up there? Do you have
I shoot them myself. Yeah. Yeah. That's
a man. That's a manly asking to do it.
Well, you're going to do a
lot of manly shit. I noticed.
I know I'm probably compensating for
something. I didn't want to say that,
but yeah, it's funny cause
inevitable. But like you do a lot of,
I noticed that it whole MMA stand up
making everyone laugh and then yeah,
I didn't know you were, you hunted
as well. You know what it is, man.
I don't have anybody
telling me what to do.
So because I don't have
anybody telling me what to do,
I gravitate towards things that I'm really
interested, which is why you're here.
Right. You know what I'm saying? I mean
I found out about your story. I was like,
that guy seems cool. And then I started
youtube videos like, oh, he's cool.
All right, let's do this.
Yeah. I mean that's like,
to have that kind of freedom in
your life is a beautiful thing.
And I feel incredibly fortunate
that I have that kind of freedom.
So I indulgent, I indulge it
like a little baby, like a child.
Like I just gravitate towards things
that I like to do and you know,
people could say it's stereotypically
toxic masculinity or whatever. Okay,
whatever. I'm nice. I'm a nice person,
but I gravitate towards manly shit.
I like watching fights.
I liked doing martial arts. You're like
fighting, watching fights, like cars.
I like these things.
I mean,
one of my got to pretend that I don't
like them to make other people feel happy.
Some people will feel intimidated
by that. Like, oh, it's too Mami.
Oh that's the problem is you don't
want to look like an asshole.
Which I've experienced. You know, I
look like an ass. He will tell you that.
So I'll just look why me?
I look like an asshole to me.
I'm sure I look like an asshole.
The others I don't think appreciate that.
Wow,
this guy looks like a decent guy
coming out of that fancy Tusla.
Actually,
I would think you're an environmentalist
and I probably have a Douche bag and
probably like Super Vegan. Yeah,
look at them annoying. Right?
Doesn't want your kids to get vaccinated
doing the shit you want to do that.
That's, that's definitely a big deal, Dan.
So I definitely respect that about you.
I've seen that more people should do that.
And I think one of the things that we
have a problem with people doing what they
want to do is cause we don't get
to do what we want to do. Right.
So when we see other people, they're
like, yeah, that's bullshit. We get mad.
Or we like, he doesn't even really like
that stuff. Or He's, you know, Oh yeah,
you're,
you're just falling into the typical
stereotypical masculine behavior.
Maybe explore your sensitivity,
man. Why would you say that?
Because the pitch pitches telling
you how to do shit. I hate that.
It's usually men that are bitches.
Yeah. There's a lot of those.
Funny how that works. Yeah. Any names for
me now? I'm just gonna write them down.
Write down. So speaking of that, so
interesting story for
you. So, um, yeah, I was,
I was kind of talking back to a tier guy
back and forth about being on the show.
And the craziest thing happened where I
was out here have to actually work on a
tussle related project o and m to top
secrets going to come out in a couple of
months, but basically, uh, does that
my job, right? And then I was like,
hey listen, I got to take a week
off to go out to California,
work on this project. And then I was
talking to your guy and they're like,
hey listen, you're going to be out here.
Come back the next week as well. You know,
as you could say, hey listen,
you have two weeks out here.
I told my boss and he's like, listen man,
like two weeks is kind of a long time.
You don't have any coverage.
Like you know,
I knew he'd be on Joe Rogan's really cool,
but I'm going to fucking
let you do that or not.
So made a decision following in
your light. I said, you know what?
I'm going to leave my job then. Oh Shit.
I left my job man. Damn, I left my job,
which is why I'm here. I need a
job. Joe was just fucking with you.
But you really leave
your job. I did. Yeah.
It was a big thing because I had this
whole meme thing going on my youtube
channel. Uh, and I used to say,
oh, I have a full time job.
I can't work on these bills. I
can't do this. I can't do that.
I was getting in the way and you
have no idea. I finally left,
and this is kind of
the, I was reading, um,
your story awhile back about how you
got started, the whole comedy thing,
how you went out, you flood
in Boston, went to La,
and it just felt so liberating
because literally, you know,
when you're doing something
you're not passionate about,
that's literally eight to 10 hours of
your day doing something that you just,
you just don't really want to do.
It's most of your day. It's, yeah,
because most of your day, so,
so it's insane. So I thought
to myself, you know what?
Everyone's in the rat race.
Everyone's rushing to get somewhere.
Every year you're in,
you know about Boston,
like you're rushing to get on the train,
you're rushing to get somewhere
that you don't really want to be.
You're rushing there to work for eight
hours for someone else doing something
that you don't want to do and it
just gets taxing. Yeah, it was, it
was, it was just taxing. So I,
and you're not going to do your best
with the things you do afterwards.
If you've been doing this thing for eight
hours, four hours that you have before,
you really have to go to bed.
When you get home at night,
you're not going to have the same kind
of energy that you had at noon or 10:00
AM or whatever it was when you woke up
or when you got to work your, what you,
what you're dealing with is this
past, this crossroads, right? You've,
you've hit this path where you can decide
to either not take a chance and just,
you just slowly take like
little incremental steps
towards what you really want
to do or take a risk. Right?
And when you take a risk, yeah,
you don't have health insurance,
dental, you don't have to, you know,
that's what the risk is all about,
but that's, that's the only way.
And people were like, good,
but would have a fool.
But you can't think like that
because if you think like that,
you're going to fail set. And
second of all, yeah, you might.
But then you got to do it again.
And if you continue to just fail and do
it again one day you'll figure out why
you were failing.
If you're paying attention and if you're
doing your work and then you'll find
something that you can do
that you're successful at.
If somebody wants to hire you,
if you're good at your job,
if you go to a place and you're
valuable to that employer,
you could be valuable to yourself.
You just got to figure out how to do it
or what it is that you want to do that
you could do without having a boss
without, and something that feels natural,
something that you are,
you're,
you gravitate towards when you get up in
the morning and go, I'm fucking pumped.
I'm going to like, I want to do it
myself and I'm gonna do my thing. Right.
There's not a time or ever come here
to do a podcast where I go, fuck,
I can't believe I have to do this. Right.
Not a time. I've makes me feel good.
Thank you. Not Today. Not ever. Never.
I mean, there's times where I leave.
I was like,
what the fuck was that about?
I can imagine there's a couple in a
thousand, whatever podcasts I've done,
there's only been like a small
handful of those that had been like,
what the fuck was that? Right.
If you can do that, man,
if you can find that
thing that you love to do,
whether it's making furniture or
fucking painting or whatever it is,
if you can ask it, he can make
a living doing that. God Damn,
that's everything. It changes the world,
the world, it becomes a better place.
That's the goal, man. So, so we'll see.
So again, I took some cues from, uh,
from some inspiration from you when
you left Boston and you're like,
you know what, I'm going to do this comedy
thing. I want to figure it out. So what,
what was that like for you? So when did
you make the determination to say, hey,
you know what, I work at
this Gig, uh, you know,
this isn't the thing that I want to do.
And you made the jump, like what does it,
what was that like? The Boston thing
was super lucky. Um, I was only 25,
less 24 dash 24.
And uh,
I was doing standup and I was driving
limos during the day and doing a bunch of
different odd jobs and shit. And then, um,
I got seen by a manager who is coming
from New York to Boston to scout for new
talent. Okay. I just got dumb
luck. It wasn't even supposed
to be on the show. And,
uh, he asked me to go to New York
and do some spots in New York.
I did some spots there. And then, uh, next
thing you know, I was living in New York.
I signed a contract with them and I just
packed up my shit and my grandparents
were still living in New Jersey.
They live on North Ninth Street,
which is like a,
when the time when they first moved there,
it was a pretty nice neighborhood,
middle class. But then as New York has
got kind of Funky, it's like skid row now.
Yeah. Well it's just, it, it
was the next door neighbor, uh,
while I was living with him,
they broke down his house door
cause he was selling crack. Oh,
he had a dope Audi parked in his
driveway and they smashed his door with a
battering ram. And it was a, it
was a legit, it was an experience.
Sketchy neighborhood. Um, but
that's, so that's what I did.
I just packed up my shit and moved. I
mean, I didn't have any money. I didn't,
I didn't know if it was going to work
out at all, but I knew this was a chance,
but I was young. When you're 24, you're
like, whatever, insurance, whatever.
I didn't have health insurance for a long
time. Do you have it now? Yeah. Okay,
good. That's good. Yeah. You got it.
Did you read it when you quit this job?
Do you have it? Why? My wife has
it. Okay, well, there you go.
So that was a scary shit. Hey listen.
What did she say? She said, go for it.
Ooh, I like it. Good. You've got a good
one. Yeah, go for it. She's like, yeah,
go for it. Because the tough thing is
that, uh, it's, you know, I had my little,
my little shitty Lou
tube channel and yeah,
but your youtube channel is pretty big.
You're saying it's a shitty youtube
channel. We sell a lot of meetings.
It was funny. I say that, but it's
hard because I don't want to be,
you want to be a dick? I don't wanna be a
dick, but I have this massive following.
Well, how big, how many
subscribers do you have?
400 that's pretty God damn cousin or
something like that. That's pretty good.
Yeah, I'm good. Yeah, it's not bad.
That's pretty good at, I'm good. So yes,
I fixed his cars. Rebuilt the Tesla's
are shit. Yeah, it's not bad. Right.
And to think that I have a mass that kind
of falling only fixing really one car
right now.
Imagine if you put all your time
into the Bingo and we'll pick it up.
And after the show I'm a,
what's it called? On Youtube?
A retreat builds. Oh Shit.
Subscribe my scribe. Yeah. Oh, there you
go. It's great. Videos are really cool.
Oh, the Nice described.
Subscribe. Oh awesome. That's a,
that's a perfect shot of me by
the way. The, the frozen photos.
But your videos are excellent.
You're really good at it and you're
really good at explaining things and you
have a good sense of humor when
you're doing it. And it's interesting.
It's interesting stuff. Yeah. I try
to be, it's funny because there's,
I'm not a super genius. There's other
people building Tesla's left and right.
And is there a lot of other people
that are getting killed now? There is.
They're getting more involved in it
and they're starting their own little
channels and stuff, but my thing is
I want to be a little bit different.
I want to add some kind of humor and
like comedy to it to make it interesting
because quite frankly,
not everyone thinks building a tussle is
really that funny or interesting or fun,
you know, setting a humorous spin to it
makes this, yeah, no, you're great at it.
And you know when you look
at any other kind of car,
like if you buy a Chevy or
if you buy even a, you know,
a Porsche or something like that,
right?
You can find these little mom
and pop fixing chops. Right?
You can find them all over the place.
Absolutely. All around. You know,
you go to a West hills, there's a bunch
of places that fix cars, right? Hey,
did something wrong? My transmission,
can you look at it? No problem.
They put it on the left and go, Oh,
you've got a leak here. You've got this,
you got that with the Tesla, you're on
your own son. That's, he sang it to Tesla.
I now man or Nada and I get
it from their point of view,
they don't want a bunch of people
monkeying around with their shit. Yeah.
But even like Mac,
like you can go to the genius store,
which is gross genius bar. Yeah.
Whatever the fuck that name.
And that's gross genius bar.
But she didn't let me see your Iq tests.
That's a bit pompous.
Some of them people, again, not genius,
I'm smarter than you or whatever.
So you can either go there or you can go
to these little mom and pop mac stores.
Those do exist. Exactly. And they're not
approved, but they can fix your computer.
They get shit done. They get shit done.
So that's the goal for me. So you know,
I'm starting my own shop.
I'm finding a shop called the electrified
garage and that's like, well, I like it.
Yeah, not bad. That's good name. Oh,
I got some swag for you too. Um, so,
and that's the biggest thing is because
there's no mom and pop shop to fix
testlets right?
Like right now it's the only game
in town if they're pumping out what,
like 5,000 cars a week. Now we
thought it was a week. Right.
Which doesn't seem like much, but for a
small company, it's insane. That's a lot.
And he's not a day, it's 30 days. It's a
lie. It's like what, 20 20,000 a month.
That's just, I don't know, 5,000 a week.
Oh yeah. It was like 20,000 a month or so.
Geez. About that. So, um, and
then all of these thousand cars,
a lot. It's a lot of cars, right? Tell
you that. That's a lot of friggen cards.
I think they're too busy. So
it's social right now. You know,
there's only two places to fix Teslas in
my state. So when someone's like, Hey,
I wanna get my car fixed, you called
[inaudible], they're like, yeah,
that'd be about, you know, maybe a week.
I get you in like maybe two weeks. Oh,
you get you in in a week. Yeah. I'll
get you in a week, maybe two weeks,
sometimes three weeks, sometimes a
month. Yeah. People weight loss, man,
so that's the goal.
So I'm opening it up and it should be
open to probably know in a month or so and
then we'll drive people there. I have
a fantasy of one day building a car.
We're going to build a 69 Camaro.
I thought you had one. No, I don't.
For some reason we hit
with a whole bunch of cars.
I just try to have a 65 corvette, but I
just, Oh, you had no, you had a barracuda.
That's where the 70 Barracuda. Yeah. Get
rid of that. Why it had problems. Yeah.
I had all the problems fixed, but it
was more designed to look really good.
You look really good. It was a
beautiful car, but it wasn't my style.
I like a car that you can like that
little corvette that I think drives like a
modern car. I'll give you drive
that thing and handles it. It's,
it's got fuel injection
and it just feels right.
It feels like it feels like a car that
is not dangerous that Barracuda was like
anytime you want and you stomp the
gas if you've taken a turn. Totally.
Such a way is fun. Yeah,
a little bit. Yeah.
But it's so front heavy like it had a
giant ass engine and it was a, it was uh,
it was beautiful,
beautiful car.
It also wasn't a stick shift and that
annoyed the fuck it's automatic and it was
an automatic one thing here
that I know it was ill but um,
what was my point?
I forgot that I have this
fantasy of building a car,
like to spend the time and actually put
it together because I would imagine that
the way you feel when you drive that
Tesla is like this crazy feeling of
satisfaction that you,
you made that thing much like the way you
feel if you hunt and you eat the steak
from an animal that you shot yourself
right now you drive that car around,
you built that fucking thing. Right. It's
all about the hunt. Well you know what,
part of it's the hunt and the chase
though. Yeah. Because now the is built,
I'm Kinda like all right now what,
you know what I mean?
Act after you haunt act to you.
You know, you take that kill shot,
you want to do it again.
Yeah.
We want to hit something different or
kill an elephant next time when I'm in the
phone. But like, you know, I'm like,
oh, I'm sorry. Sorry about that. Yeah,
that's what I don't get that one.
I don't even do people kill
to eat them. They eat. Yeah.
Well the thing is when they do kill them
and the villagers get to eat the food,
they get very excited about it. Yeah.
Apparently elephants are delicious.
I don't give us a lot of meat and so much
mean, but that's the thing that if, um,
it's one thing that we don't want to ever
think about when it comes to like, um,
conservation these animals.
But the,
the money that a hunter would spend to
kill an elephant goes towards making sure
that the elephant population that's
healthy and patches for all these game
wardens or where they call
Ph is right in Africa.
And then the money also goes to some
of these villages and then the food,
the meat from the animal
goes to these villages,
but still you shouldn't have fucking
elephant. I feel like bad. Yeah.
It's weird how like you feel bad for
killing an elephant, but other animals,
it's like a rat. You kind of deserve it.
Yeah. Rack gets hit by a car, you cheer.
You're like, yeah, you're fucking, because
I hit it myself. Right? Yeah. We're,
we're totally w you know,
bias towards certain types of animals
and for sure it's like why we uh,
how they say it, why be feed pigeons?
But we like, we shoot bald eagles.
It's majestic. Yeah. You want it.
Do you see that Beluga whale
that they caught that had a net?
It had a harness on it and they
think that the Russians, but,
and now they think it was,
they were using it as a bio weapon.
Like they would strap a
missile to this thing. Oh.
And then tell the whale to go to boats.
How do you tell where to go to a boat?
This way I was trained
to go towards boats.
Hold and it had this
harness on it and they,
they think that what they did was they
trained this thing to go towards the
boat. It's choking the shit
out of that thing. Well it,
you could use something
like that to hold a bomb,
train it to go towards the boat and
then when it would hit the boat it would
detonate the bomb and explode.
So they must have given him this way
or some sort of food reward for banging
into the boat.
So
they cut it free of this, uh, this
harness, I mean this is total speculation.
They don't know where
the harness came from,
but I'm hoping someone was trying
to ride it and they weren't shy.
It's probably a bomb though. Pretty
sure. Pretty sure it's a bomb.
I'm pretty sure look at this whale found
off Norway coast believed to be spying
for bunch of cameras and stuff too.
I might just be click baity bullshit too.
Right. Who wrote this article? Are they
an expert? Are they a security expert?
And they just have a way of
with a harness, right. We
don't really know what that,
how often do whales would harness to
show up to the fact that you're an expert
can speak intelligently
about it.
I think that the u s government owed
it's red equipment of Saint Petersburg on
the strap. Oh Shit. Yeah.
But if I wanted to trick people into
thinking that the Russians were involved,
I wouldn't make it super obvious. Right.
That too. Yeah. Why would you write that?
We got a fake train. I'll whale
and incentives. Right, exactly.
Look what you're doing. You've got to look
into exactly. Made in Russia by Russia.
Exactly.
I would write maiden rush on it is
all in English to Russian letters.
Property of mother Russia.
I love Russia.
I think the government did
that with dolphins sea.
See if that's true that the government
trained dolphins to for weapons.
Plenty of them. Yeah. I
think US government did that.
Find out what the train dolphins
to blow up boats. Damn Dude.
What a place.
What a place we live in now.
We basically trained dolphins to BG
hottest, but they didn't know it.
They didn't know there were, at least
the jihadists knows. Right? I mean,
you tricked him into going 72 virgins
and blowing up. You trick them,
but the dolphin doesn't even
know it's going to die. Yeah,
it probably would be like, what? Wait a
minute. Well, I get fish. I love fish.
He just thinks he's going to get fish.
If he bumps into the boat,
just thing on my back. Oh, whatever.
I'll do. Oh my God. Yeah, that's it.
Yeah. It says it's a myth. Oh,
it's a matter of what's a myth?
I spread sex doll. This information.
Yeah. Well, who says that? The navy.
My stories. No second guesses
everything. Is that true? Who wrote them?
But then in 2015 it says that the US Navy,
its combat dolphins are serious
military assets. So started,
stopped and started though. So
here's the thing. Why don't they,
why are they sending dog?
One is build robots to do it because
the robots aren't as advanced as it goes
for a while. Often they can't go
through the water the way a dolphin can,
and it would look like a robot of Dolphin.
They're Dunkin to do shit.
They're always in the water.
Oh right.
And get something that's an
organic part of the environment.
And then they're got to kill every
dolphin that comes near the boat.
So they see a dolphin, they think it's
just a dolphin. Right. And then it,
why don't they,
why don't they have a missile painted
like a dolphin and the time they get it,
it's like, oh shit. Going too fast.
You creating killer dolphins escape
naval training base in search of love,
like it's accurate for some reason.
I don't know why I escaped
during Hurricane Katrina.
They've escaped multiple times
and I don't know, Howard,
if we're just training more,
these dolphins keep escaping everything.
We are going, the dolphins often
smarter than us. They keep escaping.
How do we not super smart. We not keep
ahold of these dolphins. Not on the loose.
And I don't know.
It's very confusing when you look it up.
So Ukrainian military dolphins, not
actually on loose. Who says that?
That's government G.
Dot. Gov. Hey, you know,
you're going the dolphins,
my fun dolphin factors that dolphins
and one of the few animals that have sex
for pleasure. Yeah. Other few chimps.
Dolphins, people. Yup. And uh,
dogs. Well, dogs. Just for fun. No,
I guess. Well then fuck your leg.
What are they trying to do?
I guess you're right.
Good point.
What are they trying to
prove? All right. Let me ask you this,
because you're all in the technology.
Go ahead. What do you
think about aliens? God,
this doesn't seem tech related at all.
Yeah. Um, do you think they exist?
Do you think they've ever
visited here? Oh God, no.
No. I don't think so. I think it would
have destroyed us. Really? Yeah. But why?
When we visit primitive tribes,
we don't destroy them necessarily.
Like we try to leave them alone.
Do we try,
but we end up destroying him one way
or the other anyways, I think we,
even when people do for sure, even when
we try to be nice, it's like, yeah, right.
Look at that. Try, but let's
analyze them saying a few photos,
let's give them food. And they die
pretty much. Yeah. There's always that.
There's that image of famous
image of these tribes.
People in Brazil and uncontacted
tribe and they're painted,
they're their body paint and then they
have arrows drawn at the helicopter.
Exactly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Now they
know about helicopters necessarily.
The good freaking house,
the new sun. God. Yeah.
Now they worship any religion and
I can get, see, think about it.
Imagine if you were an uncontacted
tribe and all of a sudden he's talking
helicopter shows up. Whenever I see a
helicopter show, I freak out in general.
Yeah. In general. You know what I mean?
So like imagine that's, that's insane.
Have you ever been in one helicopter? Yes.
So weird. Right? Right. Is Weird. Yes.
Wait around like, okay, we're in the sky.
Weight makes noisy. Absolutely. But no,
I think, um, I don't know,
man. I think they would've
destroyed us. They'd be like,
these guys are stupid.
Don't you think they would want to watch
look like if you go to the zoo, right.
He'd go to the, the chimpanzee exhibit
and you'd watch him swing around and shit.
People love to watch the chimps.
It's probably one of the most popular
parts of the exhibit and we love watching
them like, oh, look at them, look at them.
And if you could go someplace where
you could wash them in the wild. Yeah,
like if there was like a Webcam or you
could tune in to the Congo right now,
you would definitely, how do we, how do
we know they're not watching us right now?
Exactly. That's the thing. They
probably are. They probably are,
but wouldn't they just like watch
and observe? So we were just,
we don't blow ourselves up.
So we would never know that in
general they could live among us.
We wouldn't know.
I mean,
I would imagine that if there was a
civilization that's on the cusp of some
major breakthrough as far as artificial
intelligence goes, which is where we are.
Right. In many ways. I think that we're
all super fortunate to be alive right now.
Absolutely. Because even though this
is a time of incredible turmoil,
it's also a time of an
amazing potential and change.
I'm greedy as hell that I want to
see more. I know I want to see more.
I want to see, I really want to see a
robot uprising. I, I'm dead serious,
don't I do.
I really do.
And I want to be like 90 ish years
old and I want there to be this super
advanced AI robot just to take
over and such shooting shit.
And I also want,
cause Elon Musk has head,
he'll still be alive because it had
to be in a jar and he'd be like,
I told you so.
I told you a little robot hand I told
you and what I want to see because it's
like, it's a cool, it's a terminator shit.
Unless you don't want to see that at all.
I want to see the aliens
come in and stop us. Right.
More about the hit the green switch to
turn on artificial intelligence on what?
The aliens to come down with
their little [inaudible] hand
go, hey, hey, hey, no, no,
no, no. They wouldn't do this. US The
robot gave his cars dynamic. Yeah,
it's wrestling with him. Right. That's
going to grab your Dick like that.
I might like it.
You're going to be beaten off.
That thing's going to come in and
let me help you. But the thing is,
what's what's stopping that from not
wrapping around his neck and just crushing
it? There's nothing stopping
it. If you get hacked,
take about the same people that helped
you make your Tesla work, right?
They're going to hack
into this fucking thing.
It's going to run right through your
walls. Skynet, it's going to eat your dog.
You've seen the ones that flip,
they,
they have them on trap pieces
like Cirque de Solei actually,
have you seen the part where they actually
beat the robots and less like, yeah.
You know what my favorite part of that is?
Well,
they beat the robots to find out
if the robots fall over right.
To kick them and shit. They're not just
hida released a statement I signed.
It's not cool. You can't do that
robot getting involved in everything.
You know what I mean? It's not cool. Wait,
how about, how about a robot coalition?
Should it be a robot coalition where
like we stand with robots to say, listen,
we built these things but we can't hit
them like that. And let me ask you this.
Here's the real question.
If you're 90 years old and you're still
lucid in your, but your body's failing,
your knees are gone and your,
your hip's bad and your back
hurts all the time and your,
your shoulders are all torn apart. You
can't pick things up and they say, rich,
we can download your consciousness
into this artificial body.
It's like you,
if you were Anderson Silva when he
was 30 years old, Black Mirror Shit,
they give you the super powerful
body, right? It's, it's,
you're going to feel it just like that,
but now you're going to be like a super
elite athlete and it's going to be you
and we'll put your consciousness,
or you can just go to black and see what
happens in the afterlife that let this
90 year old body. Dot. This
is the silliest question ever.
You're going to take the bird
in the hand, right? Yeah.
WHATSAPP delight might be bullshit,
right? I can enjoy myself right now.
Wouldn't you do that? Fuck yeah. Fuck
you actually want to do it right now.
I'm not even at 90. Well I think
that's how they're gonna get us.
I think slowly but surely they're going
to replace parts like there's already
amazing,
um,
artificial hands that you're creating
and you know limbs that are articulating
rims.
Here's I think,
would you want one of the limbs
that looks like a human limb.
We'd want like a robotic limb.
I can terminator.
I don't want to terminate her limb for
sure. What'd you for sure. I want to be,
want to stare at me.
But what if it was a nice and soft?
Do you think we're close to Robo cop then?
Like would that be maybe the first,
first step? Yeah, that's probably right.
They probably gonna do
that with like soldiers.
Chefy all the money's in military.
They'll drop the skeleton.
Drop 10 billion on that. I
met with robots, I ones at
Pechanga casino at the mall.
It's the most ridiculous thing. I have a
weird, I'll fuck that thing up. The one,
the one in the middle.
I want. So like I said,
I put my hat on it and it's had freaking
out. Did they get mad at you? Yeah,
it's just, it just starts playing around
in circles. I would if it, if it had,
I wish it had a gun on it. Oh No.
People will take it seriously.
Well that's the worry
about those dog things.
Those dog like robots that they just
put guns on those motherfuckers.
That is an episode of Black Mirror. That
episode. No, I didn't see that one. Yeah,
it's called heavy metal. Really? One of
the best episodes. This lady's run out.
Spoiler ladies running from these robots
had dogs. Not the head of that raw dog.
Looks like one of those things.
Yeah, I gotta check that out. Yeah.
And it has potential like actual
real technology that it's using.
So like it's not outlandish.
The thing is about Black Mirror,
everything is like that could
happen 100% but yeah, even a whole,
the thing with the implant memories
and you like live this crazy fake life,
right.
That's all that's on the horizon.
So you know what the interesting part
about Black Mirror is that there's a pro
and a con to everything,
right? So there was a,
an episode where a woman wanted to
keep better track of her daughter.
So she implanted that ship so she could
see whatever her daughter sees, right?
Then her daughter got older
and older and she said,
see some wild shit that the kid was doing.
Right?
But then to your example,
what would be the downside of putting my
consciousness in someone with a jacket
and like ripped body?
Well,
the downside would be would you even
really be a human anymore or would you be
some sort of a thing that we've created
that keeps your brain alive? Right?
But who cares? Who does care?
Well, well, here's the thing.
Would you want to live
a whole nother life?
Like how much time do you want in this
fake body? Do you want to be a mortal?
Do you want to keep going
forever? Not Forever now. I mean,
what do well at 200 years?
You know there's an old story about that,
about a guy,
God dammit.
It's like an old legend about a man who
kept killing his sons in order to live
longer. That God came to him and
told him if you kill the son,
and he lived to be like
thousands of years old,
but he just had no one around him.
They cared about him and love somebody,
a job in the Bible, something like that.
Whatever. Keep going since from something.
Yeah, I don't remember. But the point
is like when you got to 200 years,
if you said, okay, I'm going to take this
body and we live in it for 200 years,
but at 200 years I'll be
done. That's it. Right?
198 years comes along and you still
like a 30 year old Anderson Silva.
I couldn't do it. You're having
a great time. It's a good point.
But you might be like super wise. That's
the other thing. If you think, if you've,
if you think of how smart a person is,
the keep their shit together and they
become like a mature older man who's just
wise and understands the way
the world works as well read.
And it really is taking the time to
do the work on themselves personally.
They know themselves better than they
did when they were young. Foolish man.
That's hopefully most
of us as we get older.
But what if you could live 300 years,
how wise would you be done?
My biggest concern isn't
necessarily about being wise.
I think it's about my loved ones cause
they gonna Watch. You know what I mean?
Cause you see a lot in 300 years
you see a lot of shit. Right?
Like that's like three wives actually
maybe four six and who knows. Right.
But like as they pass you'd be like,
you'd have your kids and like your kid
who lived to be like 80 years old and
you're just like, hey, you know to get
your kid a new body. Yeah. That's more,
tend to want to go on forever though.
Cause I feel like what?
What's the world gonna look like
in 300 years? Maybe they don't.
Maybe it would be the shit. Maybe it
would be, maybe it would I, you know what?
I've done his name.
You know what might the most fascinating
thing I keep thinking about is us to
Mars.
I know Eli Musk really wants that. Do
you want to go? Would you go? Nope.
Why not interested? It's a
one way trip. I know. Look,
I don't want to go to Antarctica.
Really? Fuck what I want to go to Mars.
I don't want to go anywhere
where people can't live.
We got to Utah and the woods and shoot
deer. People live there really beautiful.
The streams and trees.
It's gorgeous.
But you were just saying that you don't
like when people come up to you at a
restaurant and harass you. So like you
living alone. Being around people though.
That's why I go to a restaurant and not
like in a cave somewhere trying to eat.
You know what I mean? I
mean, there's nothing wrong.
I feel like you would want to do that.
I feel like what? All this, all this,
all this manly shit that you do like
men want to just go and just like light
fires and caves and shit and just
like going to Mars is stupid.
You can't come back.
That's like going to the shittiest
neighborhood and the known university.
You can get to one way. Guess
what your name. Oh yeah,
we'll live forever without mean shit.
Assholes. No one cares. What's his name?
Lives forever. Hitler.
Some. Fuck. What are these?
Is this Elon Musk space station
on Mars neighborhoods sucks.
That's like living in Barstow
for the rest of your life.
What do you even see there?
You get trapped in Barstow in a glass
bubble like halfway to Vegas. Hey,
remember this? Biosphere Pauly shore?
No, but they did a real one. Oh,
that's right. We buy the actual
bias. Pauly shore and who else?
Uh, Stephen Baldwin. Yeah, that's right.
It did. Biosphere that. How did that,
that didn't go so well. Now
people went crazy. They go crazy.
Why don't we do that again? People
go crazy, man. You don't want,
they don't want to be locked
together with each other.
It's not normal for everybody. We just
stuck in some bubble with each other.
It's been 25 years since biosphere,
since eight scientists sealed themselves
in a biosphere for two whole years.
What ended up happening to them?
I forget.
They probably went on a fucking rampage.
Took more than three months just to make
pizza. Why? Really? What does that mean?
Did they bring her guy prior to Greg?
The ingredients from scratch? Oh,
of course. Oh yeah. They had a live,
they had to be sustainable inside that
little ecosystem where they allowed a
bang each other. How
could, you forbid that?
How could you tell people want to do in
general, but it's work. Work, environment,
harassment. Yeah. I guess you're right.
What does he look broken? Who's HR?
Who's going to stop you?
That's right. Who is HR?
So there's 25 people in their 25
sciences and that's the thing.
Do you think that if people,
if we didn't have laws who don't,
a lot of the society, no police, how
will we just kill each other? Yes.
Bearings because it didn't
happen. They're like, Oh,
who was the law there and the bias fit.
I think most of the time we don't even,
what does it say Jamie?
Nevertheless a team completed the mission
to merger from the outside world if
just two years of solitude. Okay. Um,
I think most of the time
you don't need the law,
but is that because we know the law exists
and people have formulated society in
the sense that you could always count on
the laws. So that keeps people in check.
I don't know.
And it depends on where you live.
Like if you live in a poverty stricken
crime ridden neighborhoods, right?
Do you need the law of their more or do
you need the law? They're less like what?
What is,
what's is is maybe being arrested a lot
causing some of the problems that you're
seeing in that neighborhood.
And there are some of those
arrests because of nonviolent
drug offenses, right?
Like how much,
how much are you turning mean?
Cause there is a certain percentage of
people that get turned into criminals
once they get introduced
into the judicial system.
As a nonviolent person person who's
deciding the drugs that you're stuck in a
fucking,
uh,
full penitentiary with criminals are
real criminals like violent people.
And then you're just a guy who sells weed.
Oh my God. Fuck. What am I doing here?
This is why it's real too. This is why we
need to analyze those, uh, isolated, uh,
environments,
those isolated ecosystems with people
that's never seen anyone from the outside
see how they handle shit.
Well, they kill each other.
They kill people that
don't pull their weight.
Should we do that both kill the week now?
I don't think so.
This is a great book sapiens from Noah.
What does you've all Herati um,
it's a great book but it just,
it outlines the history of the human
race and these various tribes that have
dealt with like weird shit like that.
Like there's,
there's certain tribes that like when
they see like old ladies that are moving
too slow and they just kill him. Damn.
Yeah. And this one guy was talking about,
I think it was that book, I'm pretty
sure it was the, it was sapiens.
I read a bunch of books or listened
to, I should say, I don't align,
listened to him on tape, a bunch of
them back to back on runs, right.
That we're dealing with this
very same issue. And um,
there was talking about
this guy who was like,
he killed a few of his aunts dam and yeah.
And they were like,
all the old ladies are scared of him
because he was the guy that they hired to
kill them when they weren't pulling
their own weight. And I'm like, okay,
but maybe that, is that a bad
thing though, because if you're,
if you're planning out a few,
that old lady, if that's correct,
if you're part of an older tribe,
if you've had a tribe, right?
And you guys have to keep moving and
keeping things going because you're going
to get killed by another tribe and then
you have a weaker members of that tribe
that are holding the entire tribe back.
What do you do? What do you do your risky?
I mean, do you, that's the real question.
Would you, would you, would you know,
would you put a bullet in,
you know,
your friend's mom because she wasn't
pulling her weight and because that,
that depends on the entire tribe itself.
She's throwing the whole tribe down.
See we, that's the thing that you do
when you don't have much. Right. Right.
When you have surplus like
we have, we, we value,
our older people want to care for them.
Right. Like, and [inaudible] and stuff.
Yeah. Like there's a, there's a
famous video of these two comedians.
You seen that video?
There's two comedians and find this
lady who's trying to buy gas with like
pennies and shit and they give her money
and she starts crying. It's a tear.
Jerker it's a serious tear.
Jerker but what happens in the video?
They give her money. They find
some lady. Yeah. They just,
they just use two young guys get
out and give this lady money and,
and she starts crying and
they just, gas station. Yeah.
It's like five bucks a gallon.
I actually used to private pain with
like pennies and shit. She's just like,
she's, yeah. And so they give her some
money and she's, she's like weeping,
you know, it's really, she, her husband
died just a week ago. Yeah. It's like,
it's heavy to turn it off. I'm gonna start
crying. Stop it. I want to see you cry.
[inaudible] don't
know. Hey, Joel was lost. We cried.
Oh, not that long ago. Really?
A cry for happy thing. Tell me. Oh really?
Yeah. You don't care for sat stuff.
Not as much men. Like if
someone does something really
amazing, I'll start saying,
yeah, you saw my videos. You're like, ugh.
When people do good things there cry.
Yeah. I get, I tear up for shit like that.
Gotcha. Yeah. Same here. Yeah.
I'm not into dudes who cry about like
stupid shit. Yeah, like having too much.
Oh God got out, man. You know,
if he cry. Well, is it always me?
That's what happens when you drive
and it says great, empty. You'd dump.
Fuck Jesus Christ. She bought an eevee.
When do you think it's going to happen?
That evs are all electrical
like with the solar. Oh,
not for a while, man. Solar density is
tough because he get a lot of panels.
But out here house. Yeah,
that's true. Well, he out here,
I think a lot of people are
rocking it that way. In two steps.
They get the solar from the roof or from
the panels and then it goes into the
battery and the battery in the chart.
So a lot of people,
what they do is they just,
it's cheaper than just get a whole
bunch of panels and they reduce their
electricity bill by not having either
the battery pack itself restore the
electricity.
Right.
And a lot of the times people don't have
a large enough battery pack in their
homes to store that energy to charge
their cars. You know what I mean?
A lot people just have the panels to
offset the price of electricity that feeds
back into the grid.
But what I mean is the car itself,
like Fisker had that for
a while where their roof,
the roof that was powering
the radio. Yeah, it's like a,
it's like a gimmicky kind of thing.
Again,
it Kinda is because you're only because
you're very limited in size and amount
of panels that you could put on the roof.
It's really only enough
to like trickle charge,
like a couple of things here and I mean
you need like a bigger array or like
heavy, uh, solar density
and that's coming.
But like there's not enough to
really like power the car from it.
You know what I mean?
While you're driving,
maybe there's an alternative
way to gather the sun together.
Raise. Yeah. Because if that would
be the most amazing thing ever,
if we all had cars that were elected,
I just ran the sun and there was
no need for oil. It's all done.
Is that the Fisker Jamie? Yeah. Yeah.
So that solar array on the rooftop,
I think it powers the radio.
Yeah. So like you have that much,
you only have so much room on the roof
and all the powers is the radio Rashan
the motor. Yeah. Reporters. It's
just, it wouldn't even try it.
That didn't even exist 20 years ago.
So who knows? In the future that would,
it seems like it could be possible.
You could figure out a way to make
it efficient and especially out here.
There's a ton of sun
out here. Yeah. Just be,
that would be the most amazing thing
on the roof. I don't understand that.
Trying to be hot bro.
I'm trying to get some dick look at her
trying to sell cars and it would start
with the glasses. She's looks really Pale
too. She's going to burst into frames.
Is that share share a little bit.
That's shares fetus.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, I mean I
think that would be, uh,
that would really be the future.
We had no reliance
whatsoever on oil to be bad ass man.
What do you think about
sticking over alliance?
What do you think about people no longer
relying on driving their own cars?
What do you think of everyone
owned a Tesla, right?
Hold that worth look like everyone put
an autopilot when they went somewhere.
Like what would that look like?
Go you, you've used autopilot,
but you can be out on the
wheel because you're nervous.
I think in one day it's
going to be amazing,
but I think it's like if
you bought windows 95 if I
bought a computer in 95 and
he had windows, it would crash all the
time. You get that blue screen of death,
right? It doesn't always work. No. But
you can rely on like windows 10 does not.
I've never had a crash. Not once. Yeah.
I think that that's what it's
going to be like with a Tesla.
I think this is going to be a few
crashes. Yeah, of course. If you,
everyone's driving these things
just going to be hiccups, errors,
software problems, glitches. Some
people are just dumb acids. Yeah.
But then after a while it's just going to
work. You know? Like if you look at the,
like we were talking about windows
or or a android versus apple.
The old android was dog shit. It was
terrible. But I have a new, a note nine,
a galaxy note nine an android guy. No,
I both, he both of everything. Yeah.
I like to fuck with Shit. Yeah. That's
why I mentioned junior. So we'll say,
what do you use two phones? What do you
need to you drug dealer work? Yes. Yeah.
Okay. Um, one,
one number I give to people
who are squirrelly or
anything suspect. Yeah. Yeah.
Like I have to, you know, I'll
turn it on every now and then.
Check texts and she's this fucking
guy. Yeah. And then the other,
would you give me one, give me the real
interesting. Give you the iPhone. Nice.
It comes up blue. If you get a green text
from me, you know you're on the squad.
Everyone text Joe Right now. I'd be like,
Hey, listen, what's his bubble showing up?
I like the idea of supporting
a alternative platforms.
That's one of the reasons
why I'm, I appreciate windows
and I appreciate Android,
but I think that apple has a better
platform. It's this a better ecosystem.
I just, I despise their lack of options
with their laptops. I despise it.
I think it's, it's, it's,
it's unfathomable how such an enormous
company can have such shit things to type
on when they cater to creative people.
Yeah. It's their way or the highway.
This is how it is and that's kind of it.
I didn't want to have one at home.
I have a mechanical keyboard.
You like love them.
Clickety you customize those at all?
Nope. Do you spec it out and make can oh,
super sweet. And I use a razor
razor. Um, once it's a gaming one,
I use it for a Thai thing. I never
use mechanical keyboard as a tech guy.
I'm embarrassed with me.
I had never used one.
I just use like the lap belt
in laptop one. There's a,
what are the benefits of it?
I, I'm a feedback person.
I like tactile feedback. Yeah. I like
the, I like the click. I like to feel it.
And uh, the same reason why
I like a manual transmission.
Same reason why I like mechanical thing.
Maybe you should get a phone that has
buttons on it. I should like one of those.
Remember those t mobile sidekicks,
like the foot phones and stuff like that.
That's the Shit, man. People had
those, those jealous. Yeah. Um,
what about um,
people that can still type with just
the key pad when they have to do four
presses to gain mass?
Yeah.
This is a lot of people out there still
rolled Nokia's that you pressed like
three, eight times to get to the e
and stuff like that. Or playing snake.
We're minute game snake. There it is.
There's a side call. Damn right it back.
No they didn't. Yes. Is that
what this is? What year is this?
Didn't bring that back. This is coming
back. That's bullshit. I don't know.
How popular is this for sale right now?
What,
what version of t mobile website is this?
There's no way.
This is from like 1986 still as
sidekicks, bro. Get sidekicks.
It says four g.
So it is world we live in,
in what do you want and who's getting it?
Who's going to buy that?
Joey's why that Paris Hilton's got one.
Let's just get a pink key.
What's that pink key four. Is that
enter go back in time? Yeah. Right.
Shift time warp the fuck man.
So that's like a Twitter feed that
someone's looking at it on their sidekick.
However,
you know what?
I will admit it was a struggle for me to
go from the physical typing keyboard to
the actual me to touch pat. It was
hard. I didn't want to let it go.
I was blackberries bitch for a little
while longer than I should have.
You have one now? No. No. Draw
something I gave up on it, but you have,
you have any buttons? Does what's that?
Tom Segura is all about that blackberry.
He's real shitting you. Do you not know
that there Joe? I know those things exist.
Those dumb don't like,
don't use this as well.
They have the ones that will
have the physical keyboard
attached to a big screen.
You've seen that? I think it does it slide
down. Yeah. Those are like all android.
Those are all android power now,
I think. Right and yes. Yeah.
All the blackboards or how about
a windows phone? Ooh, yeah, right.
That kind of faded into obscurity
matrix phone. That's that.
They clicked it and it's the mouthpiece
like slid down and everyone was super
pumped like, oh that bad. That looks bad.
Ass can't wait till that comes out. No.
Came out.
They made a couple of them just cause
people [inaudible] they're like 5,000
bucks or something. Windows phones.
It's weird that that didn't take off.
Like a friend of mine had one
of those. I was like, look,
she didn't have those weird tiles. The
tiles like windows 10 right, exactly.
Tiles are awkward. They're
still awkward. For me, I'm like,
this is not the way to do it. If you have
a windows phone now, what are you doing?
You're fucked. Like you don't
get them anymore. You're like,
you're not getting updates. Right. Ain't
getting shit. They're just letting it die.
I kind of just stuck in 1996 track.
What does this Jamie, that matrix phone,
that same release last year. Ooh, look at
that guy. He's so excited. I lost a slide.
Yeah, that's like the old school.
It had a slider phone. Oh,
you think you have a cooler? Stupid
with that thing. Stupid. Yeah.
So which doing guy get yourself took a
banana. Get a real phone. Fucking Dork.
But it does have the keypad. Well, you
have to do that shit back to doing that.
Assholes. Some assholes like t nine
texting was pretty fast that you're cocky.
Prick.
Shut mouth 13 I forgot
how to do it for God.
I never knew. I never knew ways that
touchscreen as well. Oh God, I hope it is.
This is just
navigate with that stupid thing.
I hope this doesn't succeed. Probably
got snake on the truck. Yeah,
I think it was the shit. Right? I'm a
snake. The snake. Is that a game game? Oh,
old old old games.
I have avoided games on
my phone for a very specific reason why
I have a problem with games like you got
you got, you got hooked on it. Yeah. You
have a bad ass gaming rig over there.
I saw that gaming rig,
the game room, the land,
but that's all for first person
shooters while we're here. Okay.
Not have a game that I love on my
phone. Why? Because I'm a child.
Yeah, you get obsessed with it. I
don't have that kind of control.
I have a fucking awesome game. It's
on my phone. Yeah, that's my life.
My life's gone now. You go get
the game on me. Everywhere I go.
What apps do you have on your phone?
They would ask what does keep you going?
I have a bunch of um,
normal apps like Instagram and Twitter,
but I have a bunch of cool ones.
Like some star map shit. What do you,
I've never looked for this,
but I just found someone playing
quake on their phone. Oh yeah.
Now joking with that.
Is that an Xbox controller?
It's sorta like that as a controller
you can expand your dope shit.
But they played, they have quake
three port it on there. God Damn it.
See why the fuck you telling me that?
Whenever I looked before it son of a
bitch and I think it was two dimensional
though, or not two d but it
didn't have an up and down. Yeah,
that does addiction now.
Congratulations on your new addiction.
I'm not going to do it. I don't have
anything on my phone. I don't even have,
I had chest on my phone for a little
while and I didn't even like that.
Yeah cause I was started going,
hmm, how do we get better at this?
I'm like shut them.
Try.
Then I had to just shut it off and
we put that God damn thing down.
You have to pick and choose what you
want to devote your time and energy. So,
so what do you,
what are your top three things that you
put time and interest to that aren't
your family right now? Well work stuff.
It's mostly work stuff or martial arts,
right?
So it's like work stuff is a stand up,
which is the most time consuming because
I have multiple sets tonight and I'm
always writing and there was tweaking
and listening. How do you do it?
Your standup stuff. So I want to this
shit. You want to get into stand up?
Not really well thinking about it. I
was kinda thinking about it. You do it.
How do I get into stand up comedy?
People watch my videos like while
you're kind of funny, you're funny.
You should do stand up now. I was like,
Shit, I'll trust me. I'm a professional.
You're funny. God, you
could totally do it.
All you have to do is go to an open mic
night. Really? Yeah. What? I see Jess,
go to an open mic night and see
how terrible everybody is. Right?
And then you'll be inspired to truck.
You're going to be terrible too.
Don't get me wrong.
I was terrible when I first started,
but you'll probably be better than most.
Really? Yeah, and that's all you need.
All you need is people. If you say
something, people that Ah, ah, ah,
just that's all you need, right? Just a
little chunk. One guy in the front row,
I got an ember,
like I can do this and you'll figure it
out and you'll get better at it and you
work at it and you'll tweak it.
How old are you? 36 you can do it.
You still have time. He's still alive once
a cutoff date. 40 Shit. Kill yourself.
I don't mean that. Don't listen to
gone. You'll never be any jokes, folks.
Just Joe's kidding JK. But if you, if
you're a person who can make people, uh,
and you are willing to
dedicate yourself to it,
it's not like you have to have certain
amount of flexibility or you know,
certain amount of physical
strength, right? No,
it's just can you make people laugh?
Right. Okay. Then you can do it.
Are you going to pull it off?
Right. That's another question.
So how do you get inspiration? How do
you, so you sit down and like, yeah,
this is funny. Now write this though.
How do you get inspiration for that?
I think it's, you have to be
what I would call a professional,
and this is a, I've gotten
this from Steven Pressfield
who wrote the war of art,
which is a great book and I'm also got
it from reading Stephen King on writing
and talking to a lot of different writers
about how they handle things. Right?
If you just waited to be inspired
and that's the only time you wrote,
you wouldn't have half as much shit.
Right? Not even close, written,
not even close.
Half as much good material as you do.
If you decide I'm going to write.
So I sit down and I write and sometimes
I don't know what the fuck to write
about and I just started writing.
I just start rambling and a lot of the,
like the first 20 minutes might be total
horse shit that doesn't get me anywhere.
But then I got an idea, what about
that? Well, why the fuck do we do that?
And then I'll start writing about that.
Well this is, and I'll make things up.
I'll make up a fact, right? And then
I'll argue against that fact, right?
And then maybe I'll find out what the
real fact is and see if I can argue that
way. And then I'll, I'll, I'll,
and then I'll, and I'll give up.
I get to like 1700 words, something
like that. I'll shut the laptop and go,
what the fuck am I doing?
How do you know that you're not going to,
a common thing is when
comedians steal jokes scenario.
So when you're writing and you're like,
yeah,
I'm going to do this as awesome idea.
How do you know that that content
already hasn't been a fan been discussed?
Well, you always, you don't always, um,
you could absolutely write something
and have parallel thinking,
write something and not even know that
someone's already written it. But you,
there's a difference between that and
stealing. Like, you know when someone's,
like, if you come up with,
if you look at something,
whatever it is, like I'm saying,
maybe you, your wife sends you to, uh,
to the grocery store to pickup
some tampons, right? And it has a,
the price things all fucked up. And so
the guy has to yell price tag on a Tampon,
check on time.
There has been like a hundred
Christ done bits on that, right?
And it's not that they're stealing,
they probably didn't hear anybody do it.
They thought it was funny. They
thought it up themselves and they did.
Or maybe it even happen to them. Right?
He did it. That's parallel thinking.
It's a common one.
Right?
And then there's other people that did
hear someone do it and they stole it.
That's a different thing.
That's the worst. Right?
But you could get both of those
things from that same subject. Right.
That same really common. Easy
to think of subject. Right.
There's a lot of those with cops
and donuts. There's a lot of,
there's a lot of things that
are like a part of the lexicon.
They're like a part of,
they're part of the way we talk.
There are a part of culture and you
could think you thought them up,
but you didn't. It's almost like
Seinfeld in a way. It's like, Shit,
I should happen to everyone.
Sure. Right. Sure. Um,
but then there's stuff
that's clearly yours.
Like if you did a whole bit
about how you built a Tesla,
right. You know, and that you think,
and then you've got paranoid heavy hitter
and you thought Ilan Musk is plotting
against you. You could. And that
that's something we do that.
And that would be something that's
wholly unique to you. I mean,
many fucking people
have built a Tesla. Is there even 20 on
the earth height? I at this point, yeah,
probably.
Maybe 20 let's pretend.
Let's pretend that out of 7 billion
plus population of human beings,
maybe 20 people who have done what
you've done, but doesn't it get old?
Bill does that one bit. I can't,
but you can. The same sauce.
Are you just talking about
other things then? Right?
Like you could talk about anything that
you find interesting. Personal Shit,
technology, world events, worrying about
the environment. You know all this.
Anything. Yeah. Did that whale
really have a bomb strapped? Right.
I keep thinking about that over and over.
Why not? Yeah, I mean, and then if you,
maybe it was like someone from CNN
that fucking hates the Russians, right?
You know, like wanting to blame everything
on the rush and it's like, yeah,
they got duped for two years saying that
there was collusion and that Trump was
going down.
They colluded with Russia and then it
turns out that the Mueller report doesn't
really necessarily say that.
And then they're like, fuck,
we got to do something that got
these Goddamn Russians. Yeah.
So they hired this whale and
they put a strap on. That was,
that allows a good story. Shit. I've
got a bad cough. So, so that that,
that you write all this stuff down, right?
You're right. Like you know, 1700 words,
2000 words out of that I
might get one line. Really.
So how do you memorize that style or
write it down and then I take it and I
extract it and a lot of it, I put in
notes on my phone. On Your iPhone.
It's one of the reason why I like the
iPhone ones because when I write something
in notes, they all show up
automatically. It's all sink.
But I also have a thing called Evernote.
And so Evernote,
Oh you do have apps?
So I,
so I transfer everything into both.
So one goes into Evernote and then one
copy of it goes into notes sometimes not
like right now I'm a little behind on
Evernote because I've been using just the
Mac laptop for the last couple of weeks.
Yeah. Damn. Yeah. So that's how I do it.
I go back and forth and you keep reading
it and then I write it out on paper and
the write it down on paper part is really
more just to highlight it and so I met,
remember what the key points are.
Right.
I don't necessarily write it out in
full like I look at what I wrote out and
then I say, okay, I know
where I'm trying to go.
Let me just try to go there organically.
Right. So there's one time I did a,
I did a speech in front of about
maybe like 160 people or so.
I throw some jokes in there,
which is actually pretty good you
to get that weird thing where you're
explaining a story and you didn't even
get to the joke yet and then you started
talking to people are already laughing.
Yeah. I'm like, wait a minute.
That wasn't supposed to be funny.
Exactly. It was a terrible moment.
My friend died. Why you laughing?
It's one of those things.
Sometimes people see where
it's going and they, they,
they their plan ahead and they start
laughing. Oh my God, I know where this is.
God. Yeah. They see where he'd go like, Oh
God, is this go, oh shit. Is this going?
And they start laughing. He
started laughing there. Yeah.
It's kind of one of those crazy things,
but no, I think, I think I want to try it.
You should try it because he
wanted to try. You should try it.
Most of my thing is like going up on
stage and not getting a laugh because I'm
not saying prick that's in the audience.
Like, wow, this guy's not funny at all.
It's Jesus. Of course. I have to freaking
stage. We are, we are all that person.
I mean, look, especially if you don't know
the guy. People love to talk. Shit's fun.
Yeah. Some guy goes up right in
front of you and said some shit.
If this guy is no fun lane, you know,
you're like, fuck this car. Yeah,
that's normal. That's normal. You, uh,
you're going to have jokes that don't
work and then you're going to have jokes
at work a lot better than
you thought and be like, wow.
But just I can tell you thinking about
it and you should do it like here's a
attorney,
but you're also thinking about in terms
of like the right way to think about it
like that your setups are going to
get laughs, right? And then you,
that's why it's one of the weirdest
things about comedy is that it's sort of t
it kind of comes to life on
stage, right? On the paper.
All I'm doing is looking for seeds.
Like I'm looking for points and seeds
and things that make me chuckle while I'm
writing it and then I'm
taking into my goes, Hey,
am I just fucked up or is
this going to be funny?
And then I try to bring it out on stage
and water it in front of all these
people. Right. That's
the only way to do it.
You have to really develop it in front
of people. Do you remember your home,
your old bits at all? Yeah, there were
terrible. I don't think so. Oh my God.
The earliest shit was awful. You
weren't there. No, no, no. Sorry.
The time stuff I've heard like recorded
and stuff. Those good stuff. When I,
when I'm in my Tesla. Yeah. Uh,
I type in a comedy stations.
I always come up,
I type in uh,
Patrice O'Neil and then you come up all
the time in terms of a three year skates,
bill skates and stuff. Patrice, one
of the greatest of all time for sure.
100 is a elephant in the room. Those
best thing ever. It's hilarious.
It's just day. It's awesome man. Yeah.
I just, you know, just a few guys.
You just wish you could get to that
good. Just clean their health up. Yeah.
I wish she was here today. He'd
have a lot of cool shit. Oh my God.
All the time I sit down.
I'm like man,
it profusely that he has some
cool shit to say about that.
The closest we have to him.
Today's really bill burr in terms of
like ballsy stance against political
correctness,
but he gets away with it in a way that
other people can't get away with. Yeah.
It's um, it's sad man.
Yeah, it's, it sucks man,
because it was a diabetes thing.
It's like, fuck man. Come on man.
I could have been. I didn't
know him well enough. You know,
I wasn't hanging out with him.
I was, I was on the west coast.
He was on the east coast.
Right.
If I knew him and I would have
tried to talk to him, but you know,
I tried to talk to Ralphie may
too. That didn't work. People,
they're on their path.
Yeah.
Especially comics is the
thing about someone who's
that free like Patrice O'Neil.
Like he really doesn't give a fuck.
Not Zero. He didn't give a fuck.
Made hilarious heating a fuck.
What he said about anything didn't give
a fuck with the 80s are though. Yeah.
Yeah. Just ate whatever the fuck you
want it did whatever the fuck you want.
It was indulgent. Yeah. That indulgent
translated to brilliant comedy,
but it also translated into him not taking
care of his body. Yeah. Just fortunate,
man. I am. So my big question
for you is what do you, you know,
you go to a party, right? Right.
Everyone has that one thing that
they can't stop talking about.
You have like I have a Tesla, you know,
hey, you know, I do yoga. Like, Hey,
I'm vegan. What's the one? What's your,
what's your party trick? What, what,
what's the one thing that you
can't stop talking about? Uh,
luckily don't have one
because I don't do it really.
I don't really go to rent parties. If I
do go to parties, those are my kids. Yeah.
It's like a 30 day parties and shit.
And then you just talking to parents
and they usually want to ask me UFC
questions, pair or, or they want to ask
me about like what see you on Musk like,
or you want to ask me like, what are
you gonna get Kanye on? You know,
like that kind of shit.
Yeah. What's that? So what's,
what's that weird thing feel like when
you actually go out in public and like,
you're actually amongst like
people and stuff, like what,
what are the most frequent questions?
They ask you?
Those kinds of questions and it may
stuff, MMA stuff. It's real common.
Comedy stuff's real calm, not just
stuff. Yeah, they ask weird questions,
but most the vast majority
of people are cool.
And the vast majority of people like,
Hey, what's up? Hey, what's going on man?
It's fine. It's all great. Yeah, it's
all good. If you put that out there,
like what I put out there,
I'm pretty nice.
It's like that's what I try to put out
there. So that's what you get back, right?
So what's next? Now? What's next for Joe
Rodeo? You interviewing me, ma'am? Yeah,
but yeah, see I told you in the
table you're a natural for this.
So yeah. So what, what isn't the thing
is, you know that x do it. Just do this.
But the thing is, I'm
trying to legitimately, I'm
telling you there's no next,
because you're a successful
person, right. I came in here,
he pulled up in the black Tusla.
It wasn't salvaged.
You didn't get it out of the ocean.
I want to learn from you.
I want to know the things that you do
with the thing is what I did is what
you're doing right now. I
took my own path. All right.
That's what you're doing right
now. Yeah, yeah. I mean what,
what your path is going to be.
I assume you're going to be doing
more youtube videos I think.
I'm assuming your channel's going to grow
and I'm assuming you probably going to
try stand up comedy and probably going
to like it and you probably do a podcast
to kind of cool cause he got
to the podcast or a podcast.
You never even done one before.
Tell.
People don't understand like you're like
how do I put these headphones on? Yeah.
Like what do I do with them?
I say what's this black thing in front of
me while you're doing this? Like a pro.
Yeah. Thank you. I appreciate
you interviewing me. Yeah,
I want to, I want to know,
I want to learn from you but
see that's how this comfortable,
easy nature that you have totally
translates into all these things we talked
about. Okay. Let's give,
can easily do a podcast.
You could easily do stand up easily.
100% well standups not as
easy as a piano you ever have.
Like a new standup person.
You have to name any names that they
did just sock and you just like,
why is this guy, this guy's not, shouldn't
be. Yes. Yeah. There's a few that you go,
Ooh, I gotta get Outta here. Yeah,
I can't be around us. You worried.
It's contagious. If you watch someone
that's really bad, it's one thing.
I don't know. Not everybody like Greg
Fitzsimmons thinks it's hilarious. Yeah,
he loves watching Shitty Comedians.
But if I watch someone who's bombing,
I got to get the fuck out of the room
cause I started thinking there's nothing
that's funny.
Really.
Like things that are funny don't exist
like this is because certain people,
like if you go to open mic nights, there
are certain people that are just insane.
Do you still go to open mic
nights? Yeah, I'll stop by. Okay.
If I'm in the neighborhood,
you know,
and if I know I want to
peak in like once a year,
once a year and watch a
little bit just because it's,
I want to remember what it was like.
That's what you started.
Now it's the fucking,
the wanting to get on stage.
Seeing the list of people in the open mic
night at the comedy store in particular,
the room is well lit because
they have all the, uh,
there's these signatures
on the wall of like,
like Robin Williams and famous comedians
and Sam Kinison and those, those are, um,
all neon so that when the comedians
are on stage during an open mic night,
all that neon is on and the
room is kind of fairly well lit.
And then at the end of the standup
comp, they were like, okay,
the no more open mic night,
boom, those lights go off,
the room gets dark and
then the pros go up. Oh.
And then you see this marked difference
in skill and quality of material and you
see like real professionals,
you know,
at Crista Leal go a bill Berg
Chappelle stops in all the time, right?
Open Mike Nights. Yeah.
They're no joke. Yeah.
He'll just Chappelle just show up at 11:00
PM just on an open mic night nail up.
So you get both things.
So you get to see people that have
no idea what the fuck they're doing.
You get to see people that have potential,
they get to see crazy
people that are just insane.
And then you get to see like worldclass
comedians in the same night. It's a,
it's a cool experience at
the comedy store, like Monday
nights. Okay. Check it out.
It's awesome. He used to
be Sunday and Monday. Yeah.
But then this place started getting
too successful and they cut back on the
Sunday night. Open mic nights, socks, man.
It, it does suck a little bit. Little bit.
Yeah.
So you live in a good spot because
you're in Boston and it's like one of the
best spots in the world for starting out.
I think I have to try it.
It's weird cause like I feel weird
because I have a following and it's like,
hey listen, check me into comedy
because it's like a weird thing.
They would like it, man. Fuck yeah.
If I'm a fan of your videos
and I am a fan of your video,
so if I was a fan of your videos and
I wanted to go see you live at a club,
which is going to be at this place. Yeah.
Oh Shit. What time? Eight o'clock. Okay,
let's count. Yeah. You think he's going to
be funny? He was kind of fun. Yeah. Yeah.
You have a need for people to get a chance
to see the first time you ever go on
stage too and just be prepared to
eat shit. Yeah. If you do eat shit,
have some stuff to say about eating shit.
I don't know. I Shit, you'll feel it.
Yeah. Like oof. Tastes like shit.
Yeah. But yeah, it's definitely shit.
Thanks for everyone. Have a
good night. Yeah, it's, look,
I encourage everyone who thinks they
could do it to do it because there's not
enough of us and there's only, you
know, is it, is it a dying breed?
It's not a dying breed. No. I think
it's actually on the up right now on,
I think it's on the upswing quite a bit
because I think there's more avenues.
There's more clubs to go to.
Comedy is more popular than ever.
Like if you go to the comedy
store tonight, it's sold out.
I have a show at the improv
tonight that sold out.
It's the places that the show tonight
and you're here with me always.
I work almost every night except Sunday
and Monday. How much do you sleep?
I sleep a good solid seven hours. What?
Yeah. What's, it isn't hard. Well,
I just was hard to believe. I
feel like I never, I never sleep.
I don't know what it is. Don't I got
it. Cause I can't, you know what?
You're a health guy. Yeah. How
do I get better sleep at night?
Melatonin release of Melatonin and
keep doing that. They'll forever can I,
it's not bad for you.
Really? Yeah. Or saunas good.
Getting a sauna before you go to
bed. It'll, it'll make you feel good.
I have to have a sauna.
Yeah, that's a problem. Yeah.
You can get one of them saw on it.
Suits you receive most things, you know?
And it was like a, like a sleeping
bag, like infrared suit. Really? Yeah.
They make those. Yeah. Um, so I just
go in like a, it's like a water bed,
but it's like a bag that I kind of sit
in like a bag, but it's a bag water.
It's up. It's like kind of heavy and
it heats up and it's like infrared.
It cooks your body. I think
I'd be too scared to, you know,
like a Turkey when I got out of that
thing. Think of oil to that bad.
It's not that bad. Oh, it's really good.
It makes you feel good when you
get out of it. Yeah. A lot of,
a lot of people that helps him sleep.
You have that? Like that chamber here,
that's like a once or deprivation is
that it's an isolation tank. It's,
I've heard of it. What do
you, what is it? You float?
The water has a thousand
pounds of Epsom salts. Yep.
So as he lied down in that salty water,
your, you know, your body floats,
like half of your body's above the water,
half's under the water.
So yours are underwater, but everything
above your ears forward on your face.
Your face. Yeah. Yeah. And then
the water is heated to 94 degrees,
which is the same temperature
as the surface of your skin.
And then you shut the door and you're
in total silence. Total darkness.
You can't see anything.
You open your eyes total blackness.
That's how close your eyes
and total but terrifying.
It's not because you could just
open the door anytime you want.
A lot of people think that like they um,
get claustrophobic. You feels wonderful.
It feels like,
first of all it feels like you're flying.
So you lean your arms back and once you
kind of bumped into the walls a little
bit,
you've got to center yourself and once
you center yourself and then the water
stops rippling,
then he just let your arms relaxed and
they just float and it feels like you're
flying. You Fall Asleep and die.
My biggest concern right now, no,
it's only 11 inches of
water and you're floating.
You can't drown unless he
flipped over face first.
He started breathing the water.
Please sit up and you're, you're fine.
There's no way to drown in that.
No one dies. Okay. You're fine.
You don't have to worry about that and
you floating. It feels great man. Yeah,
it feels great. It was very
relaxed. So the concentration is,
tells us what keeps you afloat.
This is a thousand pounds of
Epson salts in that tank. Wow.
Good for your skin too.
I found out about it first
through the movie altered states.
I had heard about it. It was a
movie that was based loosely, very,
very loosely on the legend of this guy
named John Lilly and John Lilly's the guy
who created this sensory deprivation tank.
Do you know where he is? No, I do not.
Well, he also was a pioneer
in interspecies communication
with dolphins. Yeah,
he was assigned to, it all comes back
to dolphins at this for this guy,
he gave dolphins acid. He was a part
of a LSD. Cool. Knows you to do that.
Who on the fifties and sixties
you get blasted. You know Aramco,
they actually shut this program
down because the woman that he had,
he had this woman who was living
with a dolphin and she essentially,
half of her apartment was underwater like
she was. Her house was half submerged,
so the Dolphin would come in and out of
the house and sleep with her and then go
into a tank like her husband or something.
That was the problem.
She was jerking the dolphin
off. Oh, the dolphin.
Like it would be distracted all the time,
but the dolphin stayed.
We'll of course get jerked off all
the time. So they were like, Whoa,
we're paying for what they were trying to
teach the dolphin to talk. Right, right.
So they're trying to
teach the dolphin words,
but the problem was Darwin's
don't have lips. They don't,
they can't make the deal.
They can make sounds.
Courts can't make victims what we do. So
they were trying to get it to go how la,
I was like, ah, a lot of work for
this, a lot of work for hello.
But it was really obvious that they have
some sort of language and so literally
who is obsessed with it.
He would set up a sensory deprivation
tank right outside the dolphin tank and
take acid and give acid to the dolphins.
And he was trying to
communicate with them.
He was trying to communicate with them
like in some sort of a like neighboring
dimension. Right. He was
a trip. I mean that guy,
he would take intramuscular ketamine
shooting into his, his meat of his body.
And then lie in the tank and have these
crazy ketamine trips while he's in the
tank. Why? Well, I don't know cause
I've never experienced ketamine.
But apparently there's something about
that particular drug that lends itself
very well to the sensory deprivation
experience, at least for Lilly.
And then you've got very
addictive to you about the tank.
When I heard about that and then I read
a book called the deep self and that was
a book that Lilli wrote about it.
I think that one each,
he even had instruction
on how to build a tank.
He actually had like a set
up, um, like all these uh,
plans or how you like a blueprint
for how to build your own tank,
used water bed liners and said
probably pretty easy, right?
You get a kitty pool through all that.
People have done it.
People who've done lay down, yeah,
you can do it, but you have, you know,
you really need, um, is there
a filter at all? Probably not.
Very heavy duty filtration system. Really.
Yeah, because the one that I have is uh,
it's a company called the float lab
and the float lab is like the best,
they make the best tanks
and the guy who makes his,
my friend crash and he's
like a super scientist dude.
He's a mad genius when it comes to tanks.
He's like over engineering everything
and making everything like,
cause it's like complicated as
I'll show you the whole system.
It's like all that stuff that's in the
back of it is like essentially from a
public water purification system.
It's super,
super heavy duty purification and even
pumps ozone into the water. Oh no shit.
So what do you do when, so like let's
just say like someone were to go in there,
right? Yeah. He just had a fight.
Whatever. It may spot. You want to relax,
you go in there when the person comes
out is does the water change or was it
just a filtered system with
water to be filtered, but nobody,
the only people that have been in that
thing or I'm Dan Harris from good morning
America and me. Really? Yeah.
He's the only one that ever took me
up on the offer to climb in there.
Most guys go, yeah, yeah. I'll go
in there and then they go room.
That's basically what I did.
He's like, you should go. And
I was like, yeah, awesome.
Love you buddy. Take all your clothes
off and climb into my little tank.
Literally. Yeah. I was
stripped naked, rich,
but there's definitely no cameras there.
I worry about that. How do I know that?
That out of your head? Yeah. Trust me.
I'm going to bed. I guarantee you Boston,
but Google sensory
deprivation tanks in Boston,
but guarantee you public
service thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a lot of places where you'd
go and you'd rent him and it's like,
you know, 50 bucks for
an hour or something like
that. That's not bad at all.
It's worth it, man. There you go. Float
restoration therapy.
Where's it that flip Boston discourage
and relaxed and everywhere you go,
$80 for 90 minutes in
Somerville, in Medford Street.
In Summerville. There you go.
What if I come out 90 minutes thought
that was a risk, right? Well, I hope not.
Hope nobody steals your clothes usually
like you're in a room and you get to
lock it. I'll look shit dude, kids
do it too. It was the kid in there.
My kids are scared of it.
But yeah,
they could do it where like they
draw the line with Daddy, what not.
It shouldn't floating. Wow. Delete.
Bear me. But they won't float.
You want float too weird. Oh
my God. It feels great man.
I'm telling you everybody.
And it's also a great way for your
body to absorb magnesium because the,
you know, Epsom salt baths are great
when you have sore muscles. Well,
when you get into this, this
is so much Epsom salts. Yeah.
You float in it and you, your, your
muscles loosen up and it, it kind of like,
like all we'll impingements
tight areas loosened.
I will pod you also looks like a
safe. Yeah. It's much bigger. Yes.
See this is a cause. You're a two
person tank. No, we want to go.
You can't go with another person.
Right. That will be growing.
If your wife wanted to go on
command should be talking about it.
Talking about nothing.
Yeah. Not here to talk.
That's why I'm here not to talk to you
before we go into the next dimension.
I have to know about the curtains. I
wanted to buy these characters. Yeah.
What does it somebody new lilypad a
float tank that hides in a day bed. Bam.
Somadi is the company that I bought my
first tank from. They make great stuff.
So that is a, it looks terrifying
though. What if someone's sitting on it,
you can't get out. Oh, that's true. Like,
Hey, really can you get off this thing?
I really want to get out of
here. I'm getting scared. Right.
If like a fat dude gets drunk
and falls asleep on the lid
and you ran out of,
you can't run in the air and there's
like a Arab bro so eventually you could
know nothing on the air and they
don't do this to me. It's actually,
there's actually a variable speed fan
and the one that I have that pumps in
oxygen. Okay. Clean, purified air.
So purifies the air and pumps it in.
It's not everyone's,
is that safe though?
If I go there and like it's like a
sealed system. That one right there,
the day bed one could be a real issue.
If you have said drunk fat guy, rich,
you have 37 minutes of air left.
Yeah, it's like an escape room.
That's another one that's coming to space
as the lights on it. What Jamie said,
this is what yours looks like, but
it has light. Well that's similar.
It looks like Sorta, sorta
not black. It's like whoa.
Mine is mine is the state of the art.
You have lights inside the earth? No,
there's no lights. Lights, Bro.
I know what I'm doing. I've been,
I had one of these in 2002 so I've
had one forever. I loved them.
We should all love them.
Yeah.
I think they're one of the best tools
ever for like thinking what else is a good
thing to marijuana? Yeah,
I heard you like marijuana.
I, you know what? I have interesting thing
for you. What are you going well things.
Um, so because I'm on a budget,
it looked my job and everything.
I stayed at a hostel because I'm
doing some broke people's shit. Right.
You're saying hostile? Probably not. No,
I've never stayed at a hostel in case
you don't know what a hospital is,
which everyone listening to
songs with a hostile is it's,
I shared a room with three other people
in the lung. That's right. Right.
So you know, Massachusetts
just said, hey listen,
you know we're going to allow marijuana,
but it's still kind of like a taboo thing.
Right.
They don't want it getting too widespread.
So when I came here to the hostile, uh,
I walked in and there's a giant bag of
marijuana on the table and I was like,
I'm sorry if someone's selling this.
Is this like, no, it's for you man.
Like we welcome our guests like this.
You could have as much as you want.
I'll say, where am I? Are you crazy?
It's crazy shit. Now he reels
smoke box the other day. Yeah.
I think I'm just starting to be non,
not high really from that,
from the other day. Is it out? I don't
know if he's released it yet. Anyway,
they gave me a bag of weed that every
time I open up the trunk of my Tusla,
it's like, whoa. So
what? So in over a skunk,
I'm not very familiar with
with smoking marijuana.
I think I've done it like once you worked
for the government, I don't know. Uh,
so I don't like once and it's like I try
to be cool like, yeah, you smoke, right?
I'm like, AH, yeah. Who Does
it right then? So I was told,
they offered me this big bag of
weed and I was like by should be,
because the thing is like if I try it
right, I want to be where I'm somewhere,
well, I mean say I'm going to
do crow. It's only marijuana.
It's not like, you know,
you don't want to freak out.
Right. That could happen and you,
you should only take a little,
I'll if you're gonna,
if you're gonna this is what you
do. You go like this, like this,
like it's a little, yeah,
just a touch. You know,
there's a smoke box. First of
all, be real. Smoked me in a coma.
I quit maybe five minutes into
the smoke box and I was like,
what in the fuck am I doing? We got high
before we got into the smoke box too,
that so many souls of stones. So smoke
box and ubiquity where you were in a car.
It was like a dedicated system. That's the
car. It's a an old Cadillac. Barbecued.
I am. I can't even keep my eyes open.
Wait, that's you? Yeah. I'm like,
I can't believe he's still smoke. Doesn't
even look like you. Exactly. I'm so high.
I'm in another dimension.
Holy Shit. Let's look.
Your frigging great
grandfather look good to me.
That's low lighting, but
the uh, that's crazy.
What be real does is he gets you in that
car and then everybody has a fat tube,
a big giant joint of the most
ridiculous weed on the planet earth.
There's none stronger, so why
not? So I don't understand.
What's the point of having a joint?
Just go in the car and get high that way,
but he's so hot. You can't
breathe. There's no air in there.
When I got out of there,
my inside of my mouth was cooked.
If he's never smoked weed, he doesn't
understand the hotbox constantly.
I don't understand. This is all new to
me. All that smoke you're breathing in,
right? So you're, you're smoking it,
so you're getting high from that and then
you breathe into other people smoked.
You get an extra hot. That's
what I'm saying. There's no air.
So why don't just go in there and
just be like, Hey, you know what?
I'm just gonna sit in here for five
minutes and get high. Then yeah,
you'd get high from that. I probably
wouldn't get really high from approach.
Your professional, he smoked
every day? No. Okay. Every
other day. No Sundays on now,
but I've been taking this stuff
every day. What is that? It's a DMT.
This is with THC.
It's 10 milligrams of THC
and 10 milligrams of CBD.
So it's not a lot of THC,
but it's enough.
So you just put those pills and
like your coffee or something?
I'll just swallow it.
It's like a little gel cap.
Well isn't that like not fun because it's
not, you're not smoking it. So I said,
oh like it's like a fish oil pill.
Exactly. But it's CBD oil with THC.
It's a hemp oil. So you just pop it
in and you're like, oh swallow it. No,
I take that back. I did have a
marijuana chocolate one. Was this? Yeah.
This was like, uh, last year. How'd it
go? Nothing. It was, it was like nothing.
I probably didn't take enough.
My friends,
like he didn't take it off so
I had it and then like an hour,
hour and hour later, this
is dumb. I just sat there,
I got a little high and I was just like,
Nah,
it wore off and went to sleep and it
was fine. I didn't take an off. Oh yeah,
you definitely didn't took it out.
Yeah, I was worried the other way. Yeah,
just way too much.
Like this is dumb and they have like
five more pieces of chalk. Exactly.
That's what people do.
The worst thing anybody could ever
say when they eat pot is, man,
I don't feel shit is dumb. And
then they take another one. Yeah.
And then it kicks in and then it gets
into your DNA and you're like, oh,
then your kids are high
and then you're on a ride.
You're on a ride for like
hours. Really? Oh my God.
I have a friend who ate too many edibles
and he was high for 27 or 28 hours.
Wow. A full day later, he was still high
and it took like four hours after that.
What is this guy's doing? The
leaf blower. What does that do?
And he's making a giant a hotbox
out of this. Oh, whoa. That's crazy.
What it gets and why you would want to
see some stoners like that girl right
there. They just get too high. Yeah,
like me. So it wasn't the hot hotbox
like what can you not do everything.
You can't do anything.
Is it like getting drunk? No,
no, no, no. You get paranoid.
You get freaked out and think about
people you fingered in high school. Oh,
you start,
he'll fucking,
you comb over everything
you've ever done ever.
That might be even remotely questionable.
So why would you want to get high then?
Well, I think there's a lot of, uh,
the, first of all, that's too high.
That's like paranoia.
Yeah.
But I think it gives you
like a self examination. Um,
that I think is probably critical
for people to just examine.
Like maybe you would be thinking
about your life puts you if you go on,
like if you got high and started thinking
about this job, you're quitting. Like,
why the fuck would I stay with this job?
Right. God, it could be here forever.
You can start getting paranoid and think
about what it's going to be like 60
years old.
I'm still here and I wish I took a chance,
but now it's too late
and I'm tired or better.
You have the energy to do it anymore. I
left and now I'm on skid row. Fuck yeah,
I do. I don't think like that. Yeah. So
you think you think very positively. Yeah.
I think, uh, if negative shit happens,
like you should be aware that it can,
but to dwell on it and I think
is not empowering at all. Right.
I think what's empowering,
it's like if you were a person who was
90 years old and you lived a boring ass,
stupid life, working in a shitty job, but
then someone gave you a chance and said,
rich,
how would you like to be?
You say 36 how would you like to be
36 again with vitality and youth and,
and ambition and you've
already got something going on.
You're got a youtube channel with like
450,000 subscribers. What would you think?
What would you be willing to do to try
again? Anything you did you say anything?
I want to, I want to be, I want to live
a fulfilled life. A life that I enjoy.
Well that's you right now.
So that's how I look at things.
I look at things like what would
I like to be if I, if I was,
if I was someone who was broken down
and beaten by life and exhausted and I
never took any chances,
right? What would I do now?
I would say if I could be that guy that
that is willing to just try to just take
risks. And, and carve a path for
yourself. I would want to be that guy.
I would want to live a
fulfilled life or your future.
So can anybody could do that,
man. Anybody could do that.
That's not cost prohibitive. It's
dangerous. There's risks, but,
but that's why it's good. Right? If
you knew you could, like if you put,
you ever play a video game and God
mode and just run around and shoot and
everything, you can't, you can't
die. It's boring. It's boring.
What's exciting is you could
die, right? Yeah, I is. It's
just like real life. Yeah.
It was exciting as risk.
You don't want to be that guy who's just
barely alive but alive. Right? Fuck that.
And by, because existing exists right
here live man. So we worked it out.
You're going to do standup, right?
I'm going to hand job already.
I want to go hang gliding.
All I want to do right now,
it's just smoke marijuana and then go
online is how one of the greatest Jujitsu
artists of all time hole's Gracie.
That's how he died. Really? Yeah.
Man was one of the greatest of all time.
But I'm not, I've lifted anymore. Joe,
you told me about this uplifting
thing die. What the Hell is going on?
What is going on? School reward. If
you land, oh great. You're still alive.
There's no reward. Well, you
got to almost die flying around,
but now I'm confused. Slammed
into a cliff, bro, but waive it.
But you just said that it's this thing,
exciting thing.
You could almost die if you quit your job,
right?
And then you take a path that you
may or may not succeed on, right?
You do succeed. You're going
to feel invigorated. You
took a chance and you want,
you got here. It's like the adrenaline
rush in a way. Oh No. What happened? Oh,
she's just a mishap. Oh No. Okay.
Just watch for a second and see what
you think is wrong here in the first 10
seconds. Okay? I can't believe I can't
show this to everybody on the line.
People know what's up. Oh my God,
he's not attached. I, I'll just wait.
Who was in charge here? The guy in the
blue. He's the, he's the leader guy.
Oh, and good luck here. Oh crap.
They're flying and he is holding on
tight by her. Nana are very high. Ah,
and they're going higher. Just
to be clear, this is a very,
this last four minutes. This is like this
last four minutes. Yeah. First of all,
turn around.
Do you have any idea how hard it is
to hold on to foot to four minutes?
Even two minutes is hard. How did this
guy do this? How did he manage to hang on,
look, I don't know. Like the, the person
in blue he's holding on. Oh my God.
No one hand do.
I went to a pull up and I say this,
the house I do a pull up and
get my arm might not be able to,
the drag of the win.
How does he hang on?
Oh my God. I get down to
the bottom. It is amazing.
His grip strength is incredible.
His forearms must be huge.
His, his grip strength.
Incredible.
Because what a chicken.
He couldn't wait till they got to the
actual ground running. You just couldn't.
I'm just kidding. Well, I don't even
think the guy even really demanded.
This is a very high definition. Video
was taken off a lot. What's Gopro? Gopro.
Wow. Proper way to land
Dick First. Fuck that.
What did you hit a rock with the locks.
Ramsey. Okay. What do I owe back?
Rest upon impact.
My right wrist,
she suffered a fragmented distal radius
fracture, which required surgery.
Damn son. He got luck. But that's
the thing. So like he took a risk,
but like there's a reward. The words like
that adrenaline rush, that's an asshole.
Go hand gliding and stuff. I hate hang
gliding. Parasailing. They'll watersports.
Yeah, you get a little bit of
an adrenaline rush, you know,
if you want to live for that little drug,
that little adrenaline drug. Go ahead.
What if you went hunting right?
Also also towards bicep
tendon from holding on as long
as he did. Wow. Live Damn.
Damn. Stay alive. Yeah.
Based shopping tomorrow. Wow.
Jeez. Um, so what if you
went hunting right? And you
didn't kill anything? It was,
it still fun happens all the
time. Yeah, sure. So it's the,
it's the thought that you might catch
something. Well, it's not even that.
You don't say catch. No, you guys kill
something. Destroy something. Oh No.
Running water down. They called
harvest harvesting, harvesting and out.
They actually do, I'm to throw, it's
not a pumpkin to fucking deer, Phil.
Yeah. I mean it's difficult
to do, but if you do,
that's one of the reasons
why when you do do it,
it feels like you accomplished
something. Right? Yeah.
So that's the positive aspect of it.
The positive aspect of it is that there's
a reward. If you could pull it off,
not just that you like, like I don't want
to go running with the bulls. I lived,
I lived awesome. Yeah, I guess that's
a good point to think about it. Well,
or have the coasters. I love roller
coasters, but I have kids. Okay.
I like roller coasters for my kids.
It was just for me.
I wouldn't go to the fucking Disneyland.
But you liked them because of your kids.
So I guess what I love it
is why people like that.
They like roller coast
gets an adrenaline rush.
It gives a little adrenaline rush.
Yeah.
I feel uncomfortable because I feel like
if I died this would be so stupid that
I didn't need to do this right.
But I did this for a cheap thrill and
it broke and I went flying off into the
fucking attic point. Good point. Yeah.
You know she coulda like those weird
carnivals that like pull up townie hokey
looking ones that you pull up in like
six trucks and it like unfolds as like,
like a checkers board dues one on it
came to my neighborhood and they had this
fucking thing where you spin around
really fast to the wall for a pop up.
I took pictures of the way it was set up.
I think it's on Instagram.
You probably won't be able to find it.
I took pictures. This is like years ago.
The way this thing was like on like
five or six different, two by fours.
It was like on blocks.
So Becky and people were
climbing in there. Oh boy. Gosh.
Affect your chances of dying
at those things. I like, whoa.
How did you find that so quickly? How
did you find that? I'm a Google master.
Damn good. You're a Google
master, but look at that
thing. Look how stupid that is.
So you can see the stacks of wood. That
is so good home. Hokey as hell, man.
They had to do that to balance it out
because they put that fucking thing on a
hill. What? So what? What
were you doing there? What's
your case? We're on that. No,
I didn't let them go for a shame. I didn't
let them get on that thing. But they,
you know,
you squirt the fucking gun,
the toll clown face and the balloon
pops and you went on stupid per what?
What would you nail at at
one of those carnivals? Well,
what do you like kill every not good
at anything. None of those things.
It's at the be against you, which sucks.
So I want to bring it back to aliens.
Yeah, yeah. God. Yeah. Three o'clock
please. Please, please. Yeah.
We've been doing this for three hours.
Are you shitting me for real? Damn.
All right. If the aliens came
to you and said, rich, yeah,
we're going to give you this
technology going to be yes,
but you can't tell anyone else.
Would you be willing to what technology?
What if the government brings you to
area 51 like Bob Lasar and they bring it
down into the base and they show
you an alien spacecraft and they go,
well we're going to let you examine this.
We know that you love to tinker and
back engineer things but you can't tell
anybody or are you in,
I'll do it in a heartbeat.
Why the hell not because you have a,
you owe us the rest of the human race
like these fucking assholes and the
government, they're going to
keep you telling us the truth.
Don't you think it would affect the
whole world if we knew now honestly,
I probably tell you on anyways cause the
fact that they called the Tesla guy to
go down there,
of course you're going to rat them out.
Well that's who I would call
if I was the government.
I wouldn't call some respectable scientist
from Stanford calls cause that guy,
I would call some dude who would
be like easily discredited.
So the guy who may be like,
maybe, you know, it was a little,
a little fudgy with this science reports
suspicious that'd be plagiarize a
little bit in college, but he
knows his shit. That's me. Yeah.
No, I would go with some guy who's, um,
was that autodidactic is that the
word someone learns themselves?
Is that what the word is? There's
a lot. Right, so the word,
there's a lot of geniuses out there.
We just don't have the credentials.
Very smart people and just auto didact.
Yeah. Yeah. Take that guy, take that guy.
Would you do that? No, I'd tell everybody.
Why a hundred percent why would you,
why do you, oh, wouldn't trust those
assholes. You don't owe anyone anything.
Cause I would, I would want everyone to
know what, what are they gonna do with it?
There's going to speak out. We'll
live with myself. Really? 100% yeah.
If the government wants to tell me some
secrets, let me tell you something.
I'll tell everybody. Yeah. Would you say
that first? I would definitely tell them.
I'm telling everybody is they
don't show it to me. Really? Yeah.
I would say don't show it to me,
but that's not progressing the human
race forward because, because all of us,
the goal is for you to see
it and confirm it. Right.
You want to see a confirm and tell
everyone you're just waiting to say,
I don't want to die and I don't want him
to kill me. So I would say, listen, you,
you show me. Show me. Maybe people have
done already and we don't know damn steep.
Maybe, Bro. Yeah, look into it.
I don't know. I was, it would be a
thing where I would, in all honesty,
it depends on what stage in my life.
If I was 30 years old and they said,
I'm going to show you this, but you
can't show anybody, are you willing?
I'd be like, yeah, sure, show
me. But at 50 I'd be like,
no, no. I'm not making any deals.
I don't want to make a deal.
Or you tell me that I can't tell
anybody about something. I mean,
it's one thing if it's a business
thing, like, hey, we're going to,
Apple's going to show you the new
iPhone. Don't tell anybody. Oh for sure.
I won't tell anybody. Right,
fine. But this is something,
what would affect the human race?
How would Ald,
how would the confirmation of aliens,
the fact that human race,
you think there are aliens
now what we're going to do,
realistically you would have to have
confirmation that was undeniable and your
own eye witness that's not good enough.
Just think you're crazy.
They'll shoot you anyways.
They'll just think you're a
fool and they'll just make
you look like a dunce and
no, it would actually probably help their
cause because no one would ever believe
you and no one would take
alien seriously after that,
which is one of the arguments for like
what they actually did with project blue
book.
Like there was a guy in Phillip Corso
and Jay Allen Hynek was the guy who was
running project blue book.
And one of the things that they famously
said after it was over that they were,
they would just try to debunk things and
make these things look foolish. Yeah.
And then anything they found that they
couldn't explain, they just tucked away.
But the things that they could
explain, even if the, the,
the explanation didn't jive.
It came up with an explanation just to
make people realize that aliens were
bullshit. Right. But he, through the
course of project blue book studying now,
now you have to ask your question.
This question through the end of it,
he decided that aliens were real and that
we had been contacted. Yeah. However,
you always have to question
whether someone is doing
that because this is a new
avenue for them to make money.
Is this a new stream of revenue?
I'm going to do the lecture circuit.
I'm going to write books. I mean,
if you're a guy where for project blue
book and then they shut project blue book
down, you don't have any more money.
Yeah. You're broken and you decide, well,
I don't want to work for the government
anymore. You know what I want to do?
I'm going to write stories
about UFO startup podcasts.
Lock these assholes, right.
I mean, Jay Allen Hynek died a
long time ago, I believe. Right?
Well, Google Jay Allen Hynek
Project Blue Book Ufo All.
I'm pretty sure there's interviews where
after he said he is sure after all of
his time studying that there is
and has been some contact with
extraterrestrials. What do
you think? I don't, I don't
know. See me, me personally,
I have zero experience. Right, right.
Well, so someone might, what do you got?
What are you laughing at? Oh Man,
I don't want to talk about it yet.
You don't want to talk about
and talk about it yet. Stuff
I've been looking into.
Go ahead about this topic
that this guy worked at,
that company I've been told and
told you about in Columbus, Ohio.
He also was a teacher of physics
and astronomy at Ohio state in 1936.
That's what you think.
There's some real shit going down.
Maybe you think some real shit's going
down. I don't know about all the alien
technologies or uh, actually like what
do I beings or aliens or something.
There's something going on and it has
to do with that company and it has to do
with everything you're talking
about and project blue book.
I don't know what it is.
That's very fake. I know
something's going on guys. I
can't cause it's it, to me,
it doesn't seem fair to just
go with the big conspiracy,
but there are facts that
you can look up and find.
So once you get to the
bottom of your investigation,
you will have a report for it.
I'm not ready to cut the sounds
a little too crazy right now.
I want to leave some of the
craziest stuff out. Yeah.
It's one of those subjects that inherently
starts looking crazy until alien show
up. Right there was like that.
What was that movie? What was the,
the recent movie with the, the, the
way they spoke in like smoke. Oh.
Oh God. Um, was that big rival or rival?
If something like that shows up,
then all of a sudden our
perceptions completely changed.
Like, oh wait, undeniable.
If there's like some giant Los Angeles
size Yang floating over the continental
us, yeah. We'd be like, okay, all right.
So that's the thing. So why would you,
so if we, let's just say
we had a microscope, right?
Periscope, whatever the,
whatever you call it, to look in the
space. Really Fullscope telescope,
terra scope. If I wasn't a submarine, so,
and we see an e an alien, you know,
colony. Yeah. I'm like, Mars. What?
What would we do? We'd study it.
Yeah. We tried to communicate with it,
but would that be a good move? Like what
if they came over to us and they'll go,
oh, look at these fucking dumb champs. Do
you think these, do they, you think the,
any foreign or alien species?
We think we're idiots.
100% of really think we're idiots.
Okay.
If they're advanced to the point where
they've gotten control over their
emotions and anger, right? I mean,
just think about how much tribal
warfare goes on still in America, uh,
in the world. You know, how much,
how much warfare is taking place,
how many people are dying,
how many innocent people
are dying? It would, drones,
all that kind of stuff.
Then they'd be aware of all that
they'd be aware of are polluting of the
environment they'd be aware of,
are depleting the ocean of it's fish.
It's just pulling and giant nets filled.
We clean him.
What the fuck are you people doing?
They'd be looking at coal plants
and the president of United States,
the greatest super power the world's ever
known, saying things like clean coal,
clean coal. What do you so,
so what do you think? Okay,
so someone comes to visit us,
right?
What's the dumbest thing that they're
going to notice? The first you can say,
Oh wow,
this is the dumbest thing I've ever say.
What's the number one thing you visit
our planet? The number one dumbest thing.
They're going to see
him to light pollutions.
The number one dumbest like you are years
are shitting in the environment that
you need to sustain. You all right?
You're, you're, and you're doing this in,
it's not like you don't have the resources
to fix that infinite money. Yeah,
and we have incredible amounts of money,
but yet the money's
not going towards that.
Massive resources should be going to
removing carbon from the atmosphere.
Removing particulates from the atmosphere.
Yeah,
like brake dust and all the shit that's
in these cities and these cars are
constantly on their brakes. That dusty,
you have to clean off your wheels.
That shit's everywhere to new lungs.
Maybe it's fucking everywhere. Yeah.
It takes years off people's lives.
It absolutely does.
They would look at all that. They would
go, go, why aren't they looking at that?
Like why aren't they,
why don't they have some sort of system
in place to mitigate all the problems
that have created in terms
of like, oh, I'll mean,
oh they got rid of plastic straws.
Keep, keep the caps though.
Keep the bottles are fine.
Keep the tabs that you pull off of things.
Keep plastic wrap.
Everything's plastic.
They think of those new disintegrating
straws by the way. Ridiculous. It's like,
I want to keep around what a
stainless steel we'll should,
but you have to clean it though.
That same thing.
You can halt stab somebody
if somebody attacks you.
If you get one with sharp pointy end,
oh I'm sorry.
Did I status for punch a hole through them
like that walking dead. Crossbow Bolt.
Yeah. Yeah. I think, um, that's
the big one that we would,
that they would get. They would
go, wow, these people are crazy.
The other thing they would say
is the nuclear power thing.
Like when you find out things like the
Fukushima plant, they didn't have, uh,
any sort of backup plan to
shut the hell up, shut it down.
Like you don't know what happens if your
generator goes out. Oh, well we're fuck,
well now it's just being
really clear. Meltdown and
everything dies forever. Yeah.
Yeah. They didn't plan on that
like that. The fact that we,
they built these plants and they
have no idea how to shut them off.
Like that's crazy.
Yeah.
The aliens are probably like these
people out of their fucking mind.
They're smart enough to figure
out how to harness nuclear power,
but what they use it for is to generate
steam constant and it has to stay on
forever.
That's why they put them near the ocean.
It's like these cats are assholes.
Give me sense. Yeah. Now.
The other thing too is that how would you,
let's just say things are going to
shit really quickly, right? Right.
There's a nuclear power plant that's going
to blow up any second. Now the second,
how would you, are you like a, I know
you're an outdoorsy guy, you hunt,
you kill harvest as they say.
Sorry.
How long do you think you could survive
if things went to shit really quickly?
If you have to survive, you have
all the money you want, right?
But like how long do you think you
could survive in the wilderness?
It would be very hard. It's
not easy. And not only that,
you got to get through the winter,
so you're going to have to build some
sort of a shelter. But he goes, no,
it's amazing with fire. There's no
winter here that was there. I mean, um,
what's it called? [inaudible]
gets here in la, but in big bear,
which was only a couple of
hours north of here. Yeah.
I mean there's plenty of places where
you could drive and a couple of hours you
could go to big bear and then
you can go down to the beach.
You could experience the desert,
you could experience a
lot of different climates.
It would really depend upon where you
were stuck and what what you would eat.
So the thing is if you want
to stay in the La area,
you're dead because you're not
going to be able to eat shit.
There's nothing here. Would you stay
in your head? What would you migrate?
Give your kids and you gotta
get Outta here. So you'd leave,
you'd drive your Tesla. Which
carbon? No Way. What? No Way.
It was a big debate that I had in
the, in a crisis situation. Right.
Would you take the test though or
would you take, would you take,
I have a Toyota Land Cruiser
with a VA gallon gas tank.
I got a apocalypse immobile,
but so now I went through a big and I got,
I got shit on so much for this. I said
the same exact thing. It's like, listen,
in a Oh shit situation,
I would leave the tussle behind argued
with you about that. A lot of people,
I believe that behind,
I take my pickup truck like Tacoma,
that's how I deal with gas numbers.
500% in an emergency crisis situation.
Uh,
you don't have access to get,
what if the gasoline didn't work?
You're go to the liquor store,
you fill it up with alcohol.
We'll run where we had the hurricane in
Florida now every was saying like you
have that the gas pumps wouldn't work
cause he electricity was shut off. Uh,
but the superchargers still work and
you could get to your destination still.
And like Tesla's use less energy.
It's like at the end of the day I
happened to pick up truck with like two
shotguns and like five things, a gasoline
and be fine. I don't understand that.
They also make tanks that you can put
in your gas tank, uh, in your, uh,
the bed of your truck. Right?
Like the survival tanks,
the drive as far as you want it 800
miles. Yeah. And they more and they've,
you drive thousands of miles.
There's a guy who actually,
there was a podcast that
I was listening to. Um,
this guy who is like an extreme prepper
and he actually made a trip with one
tank of gas from Arizona to Canada.
Damn. He drove all the way up to Canada,
all the way across with one tank of gas
because this massive tank in the back of
his pickup truck. Right. It feeds directly
into his primary gas tank. Yeah. Yeah.
And you can get these, they're like
these survival tanks and you know,
they'll host like hundreds of gallons
are also a target. I probably should,
I probably shoot it. That guy's
car. That's what I think to do that.
So I don't know. All of a
sudden you're lawless. Barbera.
I know the lights go on for five minutes.
Want to kill everyone starting fires.
Shooting cars. Yeah. So, so
then, all right, so you leave,
you take your family, right?
You have your kids. If your wife, where
are you going to go? You're hopping,
you're land cruiser. Where are you
going to go? You have a real penalty.
What are you going to bring you?
Well,
you would have to bring things to start
a fire and things to kill animals. Right.
Those are the things that it would be
very important. Oh, would bring guns.
I'd bring Bose.
I'd bring ammunition and arrows,
but I would realistically realize that,
first of all,
I'm not going to make more bullets and
I'm not going to make more arrows. Right.
Am I going to do, and how long am I going
to ask you to be marijuana? No. Okay. No,
no. I'll be just trying
to stay alive. Yeah,
but you'd also be trying to stay alive
for a long period of time. Right?
You might want to bring it needs the pain.
No, really? What? It's not going to that,
I mean, marijuana for pain relief.
I'm going against. It works. Yeah,
but that's not what I use a paint at
night of the impending doom here. Yeah.
You'd be freaking out even
more. I'm freaking out.
Plenty. Yeah. And maybe I just,
there's no, there's not room. I would
bring water, water purification tablets,
no food shelters and food
that would bring food.
I'd probably been food in the form
of a heavy duty bars like that take,
don't take up a lot of space,
but dense and nutrient rich like a,
there's those green belly bars and bars.
Yeah.
Something that has a lot of calories,
high calories in a small package. A small
size. All right, where are you heading?
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, go. He goes, yeah.
You got to go somewhere where there's
animals and even then you're not gonna
make it and your kids are
probably not gonna make it.
That's the real thing is it's true.
The idea that you're going to live off
of animals. This is in the Serengeti man.
There's not a lot of animals unless you're
somewhere where you can find a lot of
fucking animals like rabbits and shit,
and you got to keep them like you're
going to have to kill them every other day
because they're not going
to last with the heat.
And your kids aren't gonna eat a dead
rabbit for sure. Dead Rabbit. Yeah.
They'll eat a rabbit. Yeah. Mike, my
kids will eat pretty much anything.
You want to start a fire? Yes. Really?
Yeah, but it's not easy. No, it's not.
If you have a string and a bow and
two pieces of dried wood and you know
hardwood and a softer would, you
can do it. No, you can do it,
but it ain't easy like starting
a boat with one of those
two months. It takes a little
while, but it's not easy.
You're better off with the Flint.
If you have a Flint and a piece of metal,
you could start a fire pretty easy.
And also you want to bring with
you some Tinder. You want to, um,
if you have some dry Tinder,
she bring that with you too.
But you're in for a world of hate world
of Shit if you want to really survive.
Right. Those, whenever I
watched those survival shows,
which I love by the way, that they're
already into that shit, they're exciting,
right? Yeah. I'm in and that shit,
what did I do? But yeah, check.
It was just thinking of that. A youtube
kind of fed this to me the other day,
300 days die self documentary of him
spending 300 days on an island by himself.
She got dropped off with a satellite phone
cause he ends up getting hurt at some
point during it. He cut his
own hand off. I'm not sure.
I don't hear because there's lots of use.
You can look it up 200 days alone. He,
he does it at the very end of it.
His friend meets him and he shows him
what he's been doing for like the last two
weeks all alone. This is a volcano on this
island. He looked like he freaked out.
He's basically like castaway at the
end of this fucking document. Oh yeah.
I'm sure.
It's pretty cool.
That's a fucking hard thing to do
just for your mind and do that.
He's weaving together ropes and
shit. Yeah. Fuck you want an island?
How long you can last? I probably
last. I'd make it maybe 45 minutes.
It depends on if I knew that my family
was still alive. Yeah, I will make it.
Really? Yeah. I'll figure it out.
Did it make it a little pig? Oh my God.
For a little while I thought it was dead.
He's going to kill it. No, no, no, no.
He kept it as a pet and like it ended
up running away. How did he feed it?
He feeds it. He tells you, it shows
you what he does. It's pretty cool.
It's pretty wild pig.
Well it means that he's on
very uh,
animal rich environment.
If he's on an island with pigs.
I had a child get something so they
kill any pigs. I don't, I didn't,
I honestly didn't watch
another tire thing around it.
I didn't watch the whole thing cause
it's hour long. Pigs piss right.
It was just really cool. And you start
talking about that. I just saw it.
He brought his dog. He's lying.
That guy's in Topanga Canyon.
He's right behind Kanye. So I
was just how he caught fish. Oh,
he's got a fishing rod.
He is right here.
He got, he had some guys drop
him off and he just said,
don't come back for 300 days if you don't
charge the batteries for this footage.
You have a cell phone chargers that you
saddle satellite or use a solar power.
A lot of guys use those when really?
Yeah. My friend Adam Green tree,
he lives in Australia and every year he
comes to America and he's a bow hunter
and he'd do like a one month trek solo
in the mountains hunting for elk and he
uses these solar panels,
the lays out and they charged
battery packs and that's
what he charges his phone.
And so he,
he got very famous on Instagram for
documenting all this in his Instagram
stories.
Like he got an altercation with a grizzly
bear and he was documenting it like
you could see in the Instagram
story of the bear standing up. No,
she looking at him and, and coming towards
him and he's, he's got a pistol out.
It turned out the pistol was jammed
[inaudible] the beer then he didn't,
he didn't have to,
but he had it pointed at the,
he didn't even understand that the pistol,
like it wasn't his pistol. So yeah,
let him borrow it for
personal safety in the forest.
And the bullet was the
wrong size for the pistol.
It kind of blew up in his hand if you're
not careful. Yeah. Something, who knows?
Yeah. Not good, but he's fine now. He's
okay. He's okay. He's an Australian man.
They're a different breed of people. They
have some shit down there. Yeah, they're,
they're the children of criminals.
The British like British people who back
then when everybody was a criminal like
you guys are too crazy. Yeah. Get
the fuck off our continent. Exactly.
Australia put him in paradise. Yeah, but
they have crazy animals down there today.
Do giant spiders and shit.
But the people are cool as fuck man.
It's like a weird thing like
somehow or another that worked.
You've and you've been there
right a bunch of times. Yeah.
I love Australia like we do down there.
What you should do, stand up down there.
Maybe you should start your tour.
We ask it, hey, go do the things.
I have no income really. Right.
Just so now. Yeah. That's for now.
That's the tough thing is that I'm staying
up that hostile really like brought
things into perspective. It's like
snoring, farting. That's what I'm saying.
People just like standing in
for me, but naked. I'm like,
Hey, um, hey, whatever. Hey.
You know, it's just crazy. It's crazy.
Grow up man. Crazy world. Listen, dude,
I gotta wrap this up, but it's
been a pleasure. I'm really
glad we did it. So am I.
Then I had a feeling was
going to work out this way.
Can I plug my Instagram and
my, and my, and my shop?
So check me out Instagram at Richie,
be kid R, I, c. H. I. E. B, e, k. I, d,
d. And I'm a youtube channel, a
rich rebuilds and uh, the shop.
I'm opening electrified garage.
Check it out. Well, thank you sir.
There's a lot of fun,
man.
And I want you to come back a year
from now saying you doing stand up.
Everything's kicking out the a
like, Hey Joe Patmos, man socks.
I was on the island for 300 days.
This sucks, man. Thank you brother.
It was awesome. Thank you.
Bye. Thank you. Bye Buddy.